[Music]
look what I become
all right so another special podcast
today with a uh with the great uh
Charlie Kirk AKA uh Andres call them Mr
Kirk AKA Vinnie called him Captain Kirk
how you doing that's I'm doing great
good morning and congratulations on uh
the New York Yankees news that's amazing
Patrick well thank you yes thank you I'm
excited about your event coming up thank
you some 30 000 people here 30 but we'll
we'll have six thousand and uh so
Caitlyn is telling me 30 000. so what is
is it is it thirty thousand or six
dollars it's six thousand I love
Millions online but there was 50 000
people there
it was huge I'm a stickler for precision
so we'll have about six thousand what
are you doing the event at uh Palm Beach
Convention Center Palm Beach and what's
the capacity there how big can it get
that that's the case it's a jostle with
the fire marshal right now got it so if
you say 30 thou and I love it when some
of my competitors would say we had 30
000 people at the MGM Grand Arena on the
website maximum capacity 14 500 I would
say yeah and I mean if you get 30 000
people to something yeah that's an
amazing accomplishment we do events
professionally we do events every couple
weeks and so our biggest event's like 12
000 people and that's that's a big
undertaking even if it's 12 000. I mean
that's oh no question about it's a
multi-million dollar budget AV schedule
calendar seating you know remote Gonna
Keep people happy security Insurance all
of it why did you give me this much time
I want to talk on the last day who's the
closing speaker yep you got a bunch of
things going it's a lot of work but
you're doing it and you're doing a great
job and you've taken it from uh you and
I first time you and I met I think was
six years ago seven I don't even know
what it was eight years ago maybe right
and uh it was at our young women's
Leadership Summit in Dallas it was in
Dallas yes yeah but you were a man
I still am yeah not much has changed not
much is changing that way a lot has
changed in the last six eight years
regarding traffic well yeah actually at
that event back then the trans thing we
weren't talking about at all that's
right the me too thing was kind of the
the main kind of cultural pathogen that
we were debating yeah now the idea of
being a woman is is now uh I guess an
open question and Society in question
people are changing their minds and
there's a couple stories we're going to
get into these stories uh first one Adam
really wanted to get into the story by
the hill Adams uh Biden's life
expectancy and its implications uh we
have another one from town hall saying
Biden has spent nearly 40 percent of his
presidency on vacation Biden skips NATO
leaders dinners uh as staff cities uh
recent workloads and he was working too
hard even though he just came off of a
vacation Marjorie Taylor green demands
Joe Biden be tested for cocaine it's an
interesting thing today
zielinski slams Biden's unprecedented
and absurd stance on NATO membership
Chris Christie is everywhere uh he says
he has doubts over Hunter Biden's
investigation either a lie or
incompetent GOP Presidential candidate
Chris Christie calls Trump social media
Behavior Reckless and he says he does
not believe the audience was a size that
they claim it was Ronda Santos says he
would be Trump's right he wouldn't be
Trump's running mate I'm not a number
two guy the Santa's donors privately
worry about campaign as Florida Governor
lags in 2024 polls interesting story by
CNN RFK says he would prosecute fauci as
president if crimes were committed he
caused a lot of injury Wagner boss
yevgeny pregosin likely dead Putin
meeting probably faked retired General
says this is actually a New York Post
story women are posting about their Lazy
Girl jobs on Tick Tock how fascinating
ESPN layoffs
and you're seeing what's going on there
with the list of names they had BBC
suspense star presenter over alleged
sexual explicit team photo scandal but
they said he's going through mental yeah
and and anxiety issues right now so you
have to go to the hospital and then uh
BlackRock Larry Fink is uncomfortable
using the word ESG then we got Disney
World has a bigger problem than Ron
DeSantis people aren't going and as CNN
apologizes for misgender Dylan Mulvaney
this next one I think you can appreciate
a lot it's a spiritual one male sex
offenders faking trans identities to
move to women's prisons very interesting
Dynamic and then Zach shows a six-pack
but I think the first question Adam you
okay yes sir you're shifting I think the
first question I want to get into is the
final here's the first question I want
to ask you okay very softball type of a
question to start off the entire thing
before you start gonna make a confession
and I I just I have to do it I know if
it's gonna affect Charlie wanting to
even sit next to me but
I did go to the gym this morning and
according to MSNBC I'm a right wing but
now you
know so next track man I can leave
you're a right-wing experience should I
are you cool with that because you went
to the gym too so you're
look I have a disproportionate head to
the rest of my body so I remember you
saying that the last time no it's 100
correct okay you look great
self-deprecation thank you what's your
been your regimen as a right-wing
extreme who likes to work out bro I uh
intermittent fasting helps a lot and
then actually cutting out all Dairy was
was uh to me it doesn't work for
everybody for me it was huge and I
already did low carb as it was so I try
to keep carbohydrates below 50 grams a
day okay and then uh you know working
out four or five years you're doing it
so no Dairy are you drinking soy no
don't be a soil
you really don't need dairy in your diet
at all I mean so if you need a thinner
in your coffee almond milk or coconut
milk you know kind of what what about
babies they need some some dairy uh
you'd be surprised yeah yes and no I
mean
um there's it's called Cassian I think
is what it's called which is the
precursor of what you could call Dairy
some babies actually have a sensitivity
to it but
um yeah I think we over overplay our
Dairy card in the west and actually the
dairy that we consume is not is I think
far far more toxic and um not actually
as helpful as the if you have like raw
milk or if you go to a real dairy farm
then it's different but mass-produced
Dairy I actually think is um you've done
your research on this kind of situation
you're offending Adam because his first
nickname was soy boys
let me let me get into them yeah I
apologize
let me get into my question let me get
into my question so uh your event's
coming up it is in the State of Florida
great state of Florida the speakers you
have lined up right now are Donald Trump
Tucker Carlson Charlie Kirk yourself Dan
bongino Bannon Jr Holly JD Vance Schmidt
ASA Hutchinson Gates Roger Stone uh
bobert you got uh pesobic Benny Johnson
Vivek ramaswani Bernie Moreno Senator
Ted Cruz mayor Suarez I can go on and on
and on and on with the names that you
have going on there's another event
going on in Iowa and it's hosted by a
company called The Blaze I don't know if
you recognize them or not they have a
guy named Tucker Carlson going there as
well and another guy named Vivek Tim
Scott Nikki Haley they have Mike Pence
also ASA and a few other people uh but
they have Ron DeSantis going to his
event but why didn't you invite the
governor to your event in Florida no we
invited everyone okay yeah just for the
record and uh every single candidate got
an invite in fact we actively were
trying to get the governor to come what
was the reason for him because it's he
declined why would he decline to a
Florida event no it's perplexing Patrick
I mean I'm a big fan of the governors I
consider him a friend I think he's
running a terrible presidential campaign
and we're gonna have 6 000 people there
but it's not just six thousand people
we're gonna have 500 donors we are going
to have 300 pastors we're having 250
social media influencers that generate
millions of eyeballs we have over 2 000
of what we consider super activists
these are people that are full-time in
politics local Precinct committee
members State party chairman these are
people that donate show up to events and
so it's confusing why Governor DeSantis
in his home state would not attend he's
going to be in the state according to
his public schedule in Tallahassee he
could easily come down on Sunday a day
that Trump is not speaking
um I think it's a huge missed
opportunity I hopefully he fixes his
error we did it per I personally invited
Nikki Haley Mike Pence Tim Scott you
know obviously I'm a pro-trump guy as an
organization though we wanted to create
a venue in a format to talk to the
Grassroots as you could tell we have
Governor ASA Hutchinson who is like the
polar opposite of where I know
philosophically but we try we're trying
to be honest Brokers okay you have 6
1000 people you want to be the president
United States come make your case I will
insist the audience is respectful and
that they allow you to have a fair
hearing but I'm disappointed Governor
DeSantis I don't I don't want to read
too much into it I don't want to
speculate but I can tell you the
response from the Grassroots the people
that are attending our event they're
confused they're upset and they say oh
this is just more of the same Governor
DeSantis is making time for a lot of
fundraisers and it's disappointing he
will not come this is the largest
Grassroots event of the summer nothing
comes even close as far as numbers
capacity influence Patrick we have 155
credentialed media coming I mean you
turn over a rock there's a New York
Times Reporter you know that's going to
be coming to our event not just that CBS
ABC NBC and what is the current
narrative the current narrative is
actually true that DeSantis is failing
to challenge Trump that's 100 true you
can see it in the Grassroots you can see
it in the audience you can see it in
polling and so why wouldn't you then go
into the arena and address the audience
that has doubts about you it it it's um
some people are calling it insulting
it's hard to disagree with that I don't
consider it a personal insult it's
politics you make your own calculation
I've known the governor for six years
now
um but this is this is a mistake for
what it's worth uh last time you were
here we did a podcast couple months ago
I don't know when it was four months ago
three months ago and I asked you a
question about both candidates Trump and
DeSantis you were very respectful of
both you said your friends of both you
were very diplomatic you were not taken
a side or the other you were saying he
should run you said this is something he
ought to do you have to get in the ring
maybe it's going to be tough maybe this
is how we learn so you were very much of
someone who defended him yes when when I
was challenging but but here's a
question for you so for me when I'm when
I'm talking to all the different cams I
have a very easy time getting a text
back a callback a message back from
every Camp except for one camp and
that's the DeSantis Camp how much of
this because this is your world so for
me all I know is how to be a CEO and as
a CEO of a company if one of my guys you
reach out to he's probably asking me so
the pace he gets back to you it's really
my Pace right the speed of the leader
that determines the speed of the past
100 right so how much of this is he's
just got a bad marketing team and how
much of it is him just being slow to get
back because he thinks his strategy is
I'm above it all I don't need to be
there I don't need to experience this
I'm going to do whatever I want to do
and I'm still going to win yeah and and
that's a mistake to think that way so
let me just kind of tell you one phone
call to president Trump he's like I'm
all in I'm there let me know right he is
earning the front runner status status
right now there is zero entitlement on
behalf of Donald Trump I had dinner with
him a week and a half ago we have a very
good relationship I think the world of
him he's a great president
don't agree with him on all the stuff he
did especially with vouching the vaccine
whatever he was a great president I'm
100 behind him and I am really thrilled
with how he's trying to earn the
nomination doing events doing rallies
doing interviews Vivek ramaswami to his
great credit text message in five
minutes Charlie I'll be there
it is very difficult to get
communication from Governor DeSantis
team I completely agree I don't know if
that's the pace of the executive the CEO
I don't know if it's a culture around
there but I'm telling you right now he's
on Pace to finish third or fourth in
this primary Vivek ramaswamy is on Pace
to be the second vote getter in this
nomination that's wild
you would say like right now he's
there's no there's no like even if right
now DeSantis wakes up and goes guys
in charge out no team man he's done it's
someone fixable I'm not saying it's done
I'm not saying that but he's trending
the trajectory is really poor for him
it's he's coming across as if he feels
like he's entitled he's he's engaging in
a policy debate where the Republican
base does not want a policy debate right
now they want who is going to go in with
a spine and honestly the balls to go
into DC and fight against this unit
party regime it's it's a lot more ethos
and pathos than it is logos so he's
entering this like like it's a Yale
policy debate like oh high taxes low
taxes he's using like really weird
abstract academic terms that I can
resonate with which is we're going to
securitize the Border like yet nobody
talks like that okay how about Donald
Trump says I'm going to build a wall and
I'm going to deport the enemies like
that resonates but more than that Donald
Trump is an alpha beast and people want
that in this hyper feminine post-modern
culture we're living in and so they look
at him and yeah he's willing to go to
CNN with Caitlin Collins and just take
questions and like you're a liar and
you're a fraud and you're a fake and so
Trump's going to come to our event and
he's going to be wearing you know big
red tie and talk for an hour and a half
and you look at him and you have an
attachment to him because like that guy
is going to be able to go toe-to-toe
with Gigi ping right he's going to be
able to who whatever world leader you
want okay and so then there's there's
this attachment where he almost creates
this like mythological
type of
um archetype where young young people
all people see it and they say there
that guy has the status the attitude the
vibe and the energy Governor DeSantis is
like yeah I did great in Florida now
elect me as president
and people like no
I actually I want someone who can go
into the UFC ring and Dethrone the alpha
and until you can go into the arena and
out Trump trump you're gonna finish
second third fourth or fifth this is not
a policy debate you know it's it's
interesting you're saying that but by
the way just a quick question are you
also inviting RFK or RFK no we didn't so
he's not available yeah and he texts me
back he says Charlie I'm trying to win a
Democrat primary
that's hilarious and I said dude I'm a
big fan of yours by the way I think he's
awesome and I disagree with him
obviously on somebody's I always have to
disclaim this because people say oh he's
the worst on these 10 things yeah okay
great the stuff he's talked about with
fauci the toxins in our food and our air
and water and how the pharmaceutical
companies are poisoning us love it I
think that's a mistake on his on his end
to not come I totally agree let me tell
you what I'll give you my because you
said you're obviously biased on why let
me say why I would say
because I actually think
you know if he goes to that event he's
going to get a different response than
he thinks he's going to get I think
they're going to go crazy for like a
wild wild for him because he is a you
know the community that can't stand
censorship they're gonna love him the
community that couldn't stand the
vaccine even some of the people that
were like hey Trump maybe the vaccine
are of case not the vaccine guy they're
going to be for RFK and uh who knows if
if even if if it comes down to pushing
the idea of getting a debate if Biden
drops out you're gonna want the other
side to want you to win as a Democrat to
see I don't know I think it's a mistake
I think he should if there's one event
he needs to be at I think he needs to be
at your event it's funny I I pestered
him about it we were texting and you
know he was sweet about it he wasn't a
jerk right but he's like I'm trying to
win a Democrats seriously yeah and and
all that and he's come on my program
before on our podcast you know people
can look it up it was a really robust
and great conversation trying to get him
back on I really like RFK Jr because
he's willing to call out the security
state and the administrative State this
fourth branch of government which I
believe is the existential threat to our
freedom and liberty and the promise of
self-government that our Founders laid
out in the Constitution he gets it he
even makes claims that his uncle and his
father were killed by well his uncle and
his father he alludes to but his uncle
in particular I totally sympathize with
that sentiment
um yeah sorry no uh from a logistical
standpoint I don't want you mentioned
this kind of just in passing you're like
yeah I'm texting JFK so yeah I'm texting
I'm not texting I'm sorry RFK all right
that'd be that'd be pretty impressive
don't get the some people think he's
still alive yeah yeah exactly the Flat
Earth Community yeah
um here's my question you're actually
texting RFK yeah are you actually
texting Trump no I call okay well you
call him
picks up the phone yeah like second or
third ring how many other candidates are
you uh calling and or texting directly
Vivek Nikki Haley I texted with I'm on
I've liked Nikki for years even though
she's totally wrong on Ukraine uh and
has really become more neoliberal and
stuff uh probably most of the field so
to be clear you're calling Trump he's
picking up boom yeah what about DeSantis
no I can't reach him
and so hold on let me get this straight
you can call Donald Trump he picks up
the phone speaks with you and you can't
even reach well I don't understand I
think Patrick would agree with what I'm
saying here because it's consistent with
a reputation he has but I will say this
Trump has uh people have all negative
stuff about Trump here's what I love
about him is he is so reachable so
accessible so communicative the guy
works his tail off like even when he was
prep that is shocked he was President
like once I needed to reach him on
something and he was in Tokyo or
something negotiating and he takes the
call and he's like Charlie I'm really
busy what's up and it's like that's who
he is it's like it's him putting you on
speaker Charlie I'm out of here but he
cares about people he cares about his
relationships he he's always been there
for me and again some some people have
stopped giving money to Turning Point
because they say you're too close to
Trump and all this I say okay whatever
we're going to be fine but honestly I
have a deep sense of loyalty and
appreciation for a man who took a 24 25
World seriously enough yeah then I'll
just take my call bring him to the Oval
Office and I he is more communicative
with me than not just to scientists but
most Senators that I deal with look so
so I have worked with a lot of sales
leaders and I know this is going to be a
random analogy but you'll see where this
goes so we have 45 000 insurance agents
15 000 active agents and I'll all the
complaints will come to me from their
sales leaders they work with and I'll
see sales leaders they develop other
leaders that become very successful this
guy becomes a gun guys what's going on
here he's sweating now's hot what do you
want to do no I'm fine okay so just text
them tell them you got AC we'll turn on
the AC you guys keep talking we're doing
a podcast so this sales leader comes in
and they'll say uh uh they'll say you
know I can never get a hold of XYZ never
I can never get a hold of them Pat I got
an easier time getting a hold of you as
a CEO then I gotta uh get a hold of XYZ
and then you look at the results they
don't duplicate anybody they don't
develop any leaders and I want to ask
them why don't you why don't you pick up
the phone wow that guy hasn't earned the
right to earn my time yet I said buddy
it's the other way around like you gotta
earn everyone's vote you gotta earn
their vote for them to say I want to
work with you I think politics is the
same way where you have to go earn the
vote of the person in capitalism we vote
with what with I'm going to choose to
spend to buy this coffee from Starbucks
or I'm going to buy this coffee from
Coffee Bean no problem that's a form of
voting right you vote in your pocket but
Schultz has got to go earn that and
Schultz if the Santa no no Schultz's a
Starbucks
so Schultz will go and sit there at a
hearing and they're bashing them
trashing them and then he says look I
think you just got a problem with me
being a billionaire yeah I started off
with nothing I'm not going to be
apologizing for being a billion and you
know what you say politically you don't
agree with Schultz but you know what you
do agree you agree with brass balls to
sit there I agree and defend yourself
and that's a tough business that's a
very tough labor intensive low margin
high volume business and you're dealing
with 15 20 an hour employees tons of
competitors by the way and it's he
basically turned a billion dollar brand
from what used to be considered to be
just a commodity get coffee what do you
need yeah he created a whole experience
I have a ton of respect for what Schultz
is built it's very very and for you to
have grown your business towards that
you know how hard it is yes kind of get
it so for me the biggest challenge with
the centers if you go on their policy
and if we were to take all the
candidates and on 20 different policies
let's just say okay and you would say
which one of them do you agree with most
on policies the census is probably going
to be up there of course but there's one
big factor there you gotta have the
audacity to go out there and sit with
people if you don't
how can the people that you want to vote
for you feel confident knowing you're
going to go sit with the Enemy and
people who are really scary who can't
stand you and the more and more you take
this approach the more you come across
as a hate to say this you come across as
establishment you come across as I'm too
good you're not on my level I know
what's good for you and your daily you
said he like the entitled like he did
such a great job with covid he's that
employee Pat that thinks his resume is
so awesome he doesn't have to interview
he's just like here take that yeah I I
totally agree my favorite word in the
English language is earn
I think our entire economic system needs
to be based on earning I love that and I
think our politics need to be based on
earning and to Donald Trump's credit he
wants to earn this nomination he's
acting as if it's an open field he's
running to win Ron DeSantis is not
exhibiting the behavior the language or
even the flexibility you know this in
business right Patrick if you're not
doing well then fix something change a
message change your approach don't keep
on doing what doesn't work I mean it's
that is the definition of insane that is
the definition of insane and it doesn't
make any sense and so here's what also
what I'll kind of say about Trump which
is
people have grew an attachment with him
throughout his him literally being
president so how does one beat Trump in
a primary not that I'm like one to give
advice well I don't know you have to
talk to the new Republican party that
guess what doesn't want us to be
involved in Ukraine doesn't want open
borders doesn't want Limitless trade
deals and Patrick you say you hit it
perfectly if you understand the
Republican base which I believe that I
understand it better than most our
podcast is the most by proportion
Conservative Republican podcast out
there Democrats really don't listen to
our show and that I wish they would but
it's this they are a scorned community
how many times from Mitt Romney to Paul
Ryan to Mitch McConnell have they heard
the same tired talking points to see
them go to DC and let them down so
they're hyper paranoid that somebody is
going to swoop in and be purchased by
the war Lobby the pharmaceutical Lobby
and that's Trump's appeal Trump's appeal
the more he's indicted the more he's
attacked they say at least he's not Paul
Ryan yeah uh and and the more and more
we talk about this unfortunately it's
not changing it's not like they it's you
know how sometimes you Stephen A Smith
will say something and let you say the
Lakers will make an adjustment you're
like I don't know if it was because of
Stephen A Smith but they made an
adjustment or like a coach who's a
commentator will say something or Shaq
will say I'm gonna make this adjustment
if I was a sinner and you're like okay
they kind of listen to what she asks it
or Kenny Smith said
everybody is saying this that camp has
to listen but there's something I want
to talk about real quick here before we
get into the next topics earlier this
week the bank for international
settlement release its 2022 survey on
Central Bank digital currency cbdc
there's results showed 93 of central
banks are working on a cbdc let me say
this again 93 of central banks 18 of
them said they're likely to use a cbdc
in the near future the jurisdiction of
these Banks represents 82 percent of
world's population and 94 of global
economic output
before we get into the story The the one
thing that everybody has to know where I
stand this is why I own a lot of gold
and not only physical gold I have it in
you know funds but I own a lot of gold
so American Heart for gold will ship
this is why we chose to uh team up with
our new sponsor American Hartford gold
we uh went through this this has been a
six month process but we finally chose
to work with these guys American
heartfelt gold will ship physical gold
and silver directly to your door or they
can set you up on a gold Ira if you have
a retirement fund that you cannot afford
to lose now is the time to call American
Hartford gold a precious metal dealer
you can trust they'll show you how to
protect your savings and retirement
accounts by diversifying your portfolio
with physical gold and silver they have
the finest products amazing customer
service and a Buy-Back commitment and
they've earned a five-star rating from
thousands of reviews and an A plus from
Better Business Bureau tell them I sent
you and they'll give you 5 000 up to
five thousand dollars of free silver on
your first order click on the link below
or call
866-939-6984 that's
866-939-6984 or text pbd to
65532 again
869-939-6984 or text pbd to six five
five three two you had a question for
Charlie I did and you actually said the
word in here uh that I wanted to ask
Charlie here you said American Hartford
gold has earned a five-star rating from
thousands of reviews and an A plus from
the Better Business Bureau not given
earned interesting
um the the question I have for you is
back to our friend Ron DeSantis
um listen it's no secret there's two P's
in in politics well that's the third P
right there white people vote it's
pretty simple it's policies or
personality I mean that's basically what
it boils down to there's no doubt that
DeSantis is a policy wonk you know even
when we sat down with him that one time
uh in that little room it was actually
kind of
weird how he started the conversation it
was just like all right guys here we go
so policy 1742 and 197 we're like can we
get a what's up just to start hi hey
guys how we all doing great you know
anything so is it you're saying that
you're you're uh calling Trump he's
picking up while he's in Tokyo but you
can't even get a text back from well no
Santa I want to be fair I mean DeSantis
if I work hard enough I can get him on
the phone but it's not easy and it's
well that's immediate that's my question
you're calling Trump he picks up yes you
have to work or earn uh the right for
him to pick up right it would be a good
word and you talked about your text in
RFK Nikki Haley or whatever you said how
much is this is just a personality flaw
that he just is a mechanical policy guy
and he's not doesn't have the just the
personality the ability to be like hey
what's up Charlie yeah I'm busy whatever
it is how much is it a personality flaw
I I don't know here's what I can say
though is that in politics there is kind
of the macro the 35 000 media narratives
right and then there's the what I call
the whisper campaigns which is kind of
hey did you notice that whenever you're
around that talk show host they're kind
of a jerk and that stuff adds up over
time that's a slow build you know that
right Patrick that's not the stuff
that's going to get The Daily Beast
article it's not the stuff that's get
the NBC but if you do that in 500 events
over a decade that's all of a sudden a
reputation starts to be developed and
then there's a truth
and Governor DeSantis did have a fair
amount of Articles back in February
March or April about how he just doesn't
like spending time around people right
well you're in the wrong business what
well and just meaning like he's I
remember this you know you saw the same
articles
we talked about it on the podcast yeah
and that that is 100 the reputation he
has in a lot of Grassroots circles that
it's super fast super transactional now
you contrast that despite all the
stereotypes if Donald Trump walked into
this room he would make you feel like
you're the only person on the planet
yeah he doesn't want that ability the
focus the intensity and his first thing
would not be hey let's talk about policy
821152 exactly you know what he'd be
doing he'd say Patrick he got some
really beautiful women out there yeah
what do you run in a modeling agency or
something right you'd like his arm and
try to rip it off no yeah exactly like
get over here you know and but by the
way if you you'd have to be the most
dominant in the room right so in that
you'd have to understand the hierarchy
um but how much is a personality flaw I
don't don't know here's what I could say
though that if DeSantis is going to keep
up this Behavior again he will finish
third or fourth behind the vague Crazy
by the way here's a story from NBC which
maybe he actually needs to read Ron
descentes says he wouldn't be Trump's
running mate I'm not a number two guy
right okay so you may say you're not a
number two God read the whole thing
Florida Governor Ron the center firmly
stated I don't think so I'm not a number
two cat would ask if he would be Donald
Trump's running mate citing his
preference to stay as Governor because
the vice presidency doesn't really have
any Authority the centers dismissed
discussions about potential running
mates asserting it is a little bit of a
presumptuous to be doing so at this
stage his Focus remains on winning early
primaries for his candidacy despite his
decision DeSantis pledged his support
for eventual GOP nominee even if it
turns out to be Trump acknowledging
Trump's significance lead in the
National server with 51 National
Republican primaril which is good to
hear that but here's the point you know
sometimes like this happens in sports
where you're the best high school ball
player and then you're like dude I'm
just I'm I'm a dog you know like okay
great then you go to college you're like
oh [__] I suck then your your senior
you're you're actually the best player
on the team like no I'm gonna do I'm
making and you go to NBA you're like you
know what I'm the best sixth man I'm
gonna get six men I'm not I'm actually
not who I thought I was I'm Lamar Odom
I'm the Sixth Man of the Year you're
Luke Williams by the way there is
nothing wrong with that okay there's
nothing wrong with that you're a guy
that comes and gets the job done or
here's the part very interesting Russell
Westbrook does he have a ring no he's
not a number one guy Chris Paul does he
have a ring he's not a number one guy
Paul George does he have a ring he's not
a number one guy you know what he said
on this podcast he says I finally come
to a conclusion to realize I will never
win a championship as a number one and
Paul George is a dog he's not a regular
guy so what does this mean here's what
it means
there's two things with uh Governor
DeSantis I'll say this and I'll turn it
over to you is one sometimes you may be
number one in policies you may be number
one in running a state you may be number
one and all that stuff but you're not a
number one marketer maybe the best thing
he could do and I'm telling you guys
right now the best thing he could do is
if he can figure out a way to be around
a guy who is possibly the greatest
marketer who won on TV who won on
politics and who won in business who won
in real estate in New York where you're
negotiating air you go and spend four
years on the under this guy you know
what you're going to learn after four
years not policies you're going to send
a room just like everybody sizes each
other up they'll say
yeah I'm better than him in that I'm
definitely better than him in that
policy he's wrong about that policy
that's not true oh [__] I can't do that
now you can't do that Ron that's
marketing and to win at that level you
need that what are your thoughts on that
he believes he's better than Trump
though he he does not believe there's a
lot to learn there that's very positive
good for you but the world has to
believe that well but also I mean like
you just said it best I mean you
negotiate the air rights over Tiffany's
that's a skill set that is a lot
different than navigating the all-red
Florida legislature like a lot right I
mean and so here's the thing in politics
you have to read the room and so you
know this in sales right Patrick I mean
you I'm Blown Away by what you do with
you know PHP all that I can't wait to
come speak in August with you guys is
that when you teach sales people you let
the customer talk first or else you're
just it it would be like going to a
bunch of Jewish rabbis be like yeah you
know I sell BLTs like okay that's that's
they're they're not gonna buy bacon from
you okay it's against their deeply held
beliefs it would have been helpful if
you knew that they were you know
Orthodox Jewish rabbis before you open
your mouth in the bacon business yeah so
but but Rhonda santis is going into the
Republican base and not even first
asking the question of what they want
instead he's like let me tell you what
you want okay no no you're misreading
the room
the the Republican base right now is a
base that wants a Resurgence of economic
nationalism they want their country back
they're sick of this trans zealotry more
than anything else though they want a
president who's a bulldog they want a
UFC fighter they want someone to get
into the ring willing to bloody up the
opposition and settle the score
literally because they feel like they
are being blitzkrieged and pummeled
every single day now to your point
Patrick yes if you're trying to create a
roster to save Western Civilization
someone's going to be Jordan until
Jordan retires yes you need a Pippin you
need a cuckoo you need a cur and you
need a Rodman where does DeSantis fall
on all that probably like Steve Kerr
like role player yeah no no but like
they don't agree they don't win the
fifth title without Steve Kerr like they
just don't Steve Kerr was uh shooting
threes that was a fifth sixth man hold
on a second yeah he was a role player
I'm saying like right now I'm with you
but then Steve Kerr when his number was
called Michael Jordan whispered in the
Huddle like yo yo Steve yo Steve I might
come to you right right game six I
believe boom dishes to Steve Kerr hits
it with seven seconds left and they win
the fifth title right that was necessary
and proper but he understood his role
and Steve Kerr said in the last dance I
always knew I was not going to be a one
guy so I had to scrap my position now
you might say oh well maybe Ron DeSantis
is Pippin or Rodman we can only play the
metaphor out so far but right now Ron
DeSantis is the governor of one state he
wants to be president of 50 and the
leader of the Free World
you're going up against Jordan man
you're going up against a guy that has
succeeded in everything he's done and in
my personal opinion was not given a fair
Shake in the 2020 election so it's
unfair to say like oh you know we're
necessarily going to lose like come on
let's be honest that election was a
drive-by shooting in the U.S
Constitution mail-in drop boxes social
media interference the Twitter files all
that stuff covet all that stuff right so
the Republican base also believes
rightly that Donald Trump has not had a
fair shake at governance or re-election
since the moment he won the 2016
election and they're right despite on
his campaign Russia hoax two
impeachments yeah he earlier you used
the word scorned you said they want a
pit bull they want a fighter yes explain
if you could just extrapolate why are
they feel scorned
metaphysical not just this is a great
question right I get this question asked
by establishment donors which I'm on
good terms with where they ask me like
almost as if I'm some sort of like
translator help me understand the
deplorable people in Arkansas they have
shown up and vote voted they show up to
church they raise their kids they pay
their taxes they've done what they've
been told to do and they've lived
largely virtuous good lives for 40 years
and they've seen their country decline
but they've constantly elected
Republicans to see their country
collapse and they've more specifically
got behind smooth talking slick
well-funded Republicans Mitt Romney Paul
Ryan Mitch McConnell John Boehner and
many others that have told them just
give us political power and things are
going to get better and they do not see
the Border getting closed they do not
see the Bell the budget getting balanced
they do not see top priorities of
ordinary everyday Americans start to get
accomplished so they start to create a
sense of scorn paranoia neuroticism or
just like understanding understandable
skepticism which where I'm at where the
first instinct of a republican-based
voter is I think you're lying to me
until you prove me otherwise Charlie I
think what you're saying is is Paramount
for people to understand and hear the
words that you're actually saying and
I'm just like oh a talking point it's
super important that you're saying that
you know Bill Maher always says it's
okay for you to hate Trump you can't
hate the people that voted for him 100
these people you have to understand
their DNA if they feel scorned they
don't care that he calls someone Little
Marco or low energy
they feel [__] pissed and scorned and
so but let me just re-emphasize this
they're not wrong like for 40 years
we've shipped our jobs overseas and we
invade a country every two years we're
financing foreign thuggish governments
in Ukraine with zelenski while our own
border continues to be wide open we have
a hundred and ten thousand drug
overdoses every single year and I have
to be lectured by the CIA and the FBI
and the a party that the Ukrainian
government is my responsibility oh screw
you I don't care about zelenski I care
about the 110 000 fellow Americans that
are drug overdosing every single year I
care that middle class wages are going
down and that we have the most suicidal
drug-addicted alcohol addicted depressed
and pornographic addicted generation in
history and so Trump recalibrates
everything and says no no when the plane
is going down you put on your oxygen
mask first then you can go to the Somali
immigrant and go put their oxygen mask
on yeah that is a very simple prudent
approach the other politicians reject
that philosophical by the way this is
one thing to keep in mind what all this
stuff is going on just a few months ago
I don't know maybe eight months ago
everybody's like well musk is for the
scientists Roman is for the santis Ken
Griffin from Citadel is for DeSantis
Mega donor Ken Griffin is evaluating the
GOP Primary field but remains silent on
his contribution to Pro de Santas
entities like the Never Back Down super
repair Griffin has previously expressed
support for DeSantis who received 100
million dollars from Griffin in 2022
midterms the Santa's campaign highlights
his fundraising success with 150 million
dollars raised overall including an 82.5
million dollar transfer from a state
level political committee so what
happens when these bigger donors are
pulling away don't be surprised if one
of two things happen if they try to
draft like a Glenn youngin to the race
as kind of the counter to Trump and or
another one of these candidates kind of
starts to get the anointing to go
against Trump look maybe Tim Scott is
probably the next one he doesn't have a
snowball chance in hell to beat I
actually like Tim Scott I think he's a
pleasant person he's been really sweet
to me and I just disagree with him on a
lot of stuff and he's not the fighter
the base wants but yeah the the I hear
this because I talk to a lot of these
donors and and they know where I stand
but I also have a mission at Turning
Point USA an educational mission that is
in wide agreement with a lot of donors
right so I I strike that balance I think
pretty well but Patrick call after call
I received from people that are so upset
with DeSantis and underwhelmed by how
he's doing and they are seeking other
options and because DeSantis was
supposed to be the guy that could
successfully challenge Trump and that is
not materializing and by the way time is
running out do you think it's too late
no do you do you think it's too late
well who am I to give advice to you know
against Trump because everyone knows
where my you know where my loyalties lie
but no it's not too late however it's
increasingly unlikely it's a 99 if you
were like the bookie like to kind of do
the odds it's a 99 chance Trump wins the
nomination absent something a Black Swan
event that we are not expecting because
the indictments are only helping the
more that stuff is in the news Jack
Smith might as well be the campaign
chairman of the Donald J Trump Super PAC
it only helps invigorate the Republican
base to play Into The Core theme of
Donald Trump which is they need to take
me out because I'm a threat to the
system so so
Christopher Ray was in Congress
yesterday not answering any questions
everything from you know January 6th to
rush everything was it's still under
investigation they're asking about
Hunter they're asking about uh Joe Biden
everything there's no answers ever
Charlie so let's say Trump does win
because I think he's going to get the
nomination let's say he wins the
presidency the doj FBI we had to talk
about this on one podcast Pat from what
I would say 95 left Democrat like what
are they going to do like does he even
once he's in Charlie are we gonna have
to deal with all this crap over again
like he's making promises so there's
there's a thing called schedule F where
you're allowed if you sign schedule F as
president you could just fire any
executive branch employee at will now
Trump because of how they're treating
him if by some miraculous intervention
he's able to actually become president
again yeah you are going to see one of
the most motivated Executives to reform
the Leviathan you're fired you're fine
but it's going to be a bloodbath now you
say well why didn't he do that first
turn he wanted to but he was really
handcuffed by a lot of doubles talk and
misleading people that say we don't do
that around here you know that's not how
it works but you must understand also
the context from the moment Donald Trump
took pres the presidency Peter struck
stroke smirk was in the White House
entrapped Lieutenant General Michael
Flynn he was under the Mueller stuff
under the Russia stuff that Chuck
Schumer in January of 2017 before Donald
Trump became president Sat On The Rachel
Maddow program said this the Central
Intelligence Agency has six ways to
Sunday of getting back at you and for
supposedly a very shrewd businessman
you're not being very smart to go after
the Intel agencies so they they set his
his first term up and here he is he
doesn't even know where the pen drawer
is in the Resolute desk and he's dealing
with impeachment inquiries and Mueller
stuff and Paul Ryan's against him so a
second term in some ways you know
there's only been one president that has
served you know non-consecutive terms
Grover Cleveland and so he almost has
this breather to come in with like a
fire-breathing man
which he speak he's not just like
alluding to it he's being as blunt as
blunt can be in his policy speeches and
his rallies of what he plans to do and
look going after the administrative
State again I will repeat is the
existential threat to our Liberty the
promise of the American founding is
representative three branch government
not unrepresentative Shadow Leviathan
fourth Branch bureaucracies running our
life I want you you brought up rate
right what happened to him with the FBI
check this out so here's Matt I want to
show a series of three things the first
one is Matt gates with Ray okay director
of FBI then it's Jim Jordan then it's
Chris Christie responding to this so go
ahead and plus the first one uh uh with
Gates I'm sitting here with my father
I will make certain that between the man
sitting next to me and every person he
knows in my ability to forever hold a
grudge that you will regret not
following my direction I am sitting here
waiting for the call with my father
sounds like a Shakedown doesn't IT
director
I'm not going to get into commenting on
that you you seem deeply uncurious about
it don't you almost suspiciously
uncurious are you protecting the bidens
absolutely not the FBI is not it has no
interest you won't answer the question
about whether or not that's a Shakedown
and everybody knows why you won't answer
it because to
they know it is and your inability to
acknowledge that is deeply revealing
about you but okay so that's the first
one all right straight up calls him up
now watch Jim Jordan because on this one
race starts then Jim finishes so look
what he says really any company of any
size in China
is required
required by Chinese law to have what
they quaintly call a committee
which is essentially a cell inside the
company whose sole function is to ensure
that company's compliance with Chinese
Communist Party Orthodoxy if we tried to
install something like that in American
companies or if the British tried to do
it in British companies or any number of
other places people would go out of
their minds and rightly so agreed well
thank you I'd like to work with you more
on that and I had to yield the balance
of my tongue to the chairman thank you
but that's exactly what you did the
judge said it last week
every week you were meeting with big
tech companies saying hey look at this
this violates your policy take this
speech of Americans down you were doing
the same darn thing you just described
the Chinese about really pretty wild
right and watch Chris Christie what he
says about this and and how he builds
this up go ahead
Jim Comey and Eric Holder and Loretta
Lynch drastically harmed the Department
of Justice and the FBI and Chris Ray has
now spent years fixing that
um now are there going to be
disagreements of course you're always
going to be the screens between Congress
and the executive branch and they would
like more information and he's got
obligations under grand jury rules to
not give everything they want to give
but I will tell you something what you
saw today I think was an animated and
combative FBI director who's defending
the men and women who work for him every
day and do a great job and protect us
from domestic terrorism from
International terrorism and from these
drug cartels and are helping state and
local law enforcement every day with
their things so yeah I I think Chris Ray
has done a very good job and I think
Luke a lot of the stuff you see today
John is theater
um the people trying to raise money for
campaigns doesn't mean there aren't
problems that the FBI there are but I
believe Chris is a guy who can get him
fixed and he's fixed a lot of them
already what do you think about this
whole you know Chris Ray forget about
Chris Christie because what I want to
know about you afterwards is with him
what he his players but what do you
think about what's going on with Ray and
oh I mean Chris Ray is an embodiment of
the toxin that is currently eroding the
United States Constitution no one voted
for Chris Ray he didn't have to go to
Iowa and convince people to give him
power he has a 10-year term to run a
secret police against political
dissidents they don't like so Chris
Christie aside because he's a overweight
Sideshow the the the the the the the the
core of this that needs to be focused
and emphasized is what has the FBI done
recently not just going after political
dissidents Donald Trump not just going
after Steve Bannon not going after
Dinesh D'Souza a couple years ago also
Rudy Giuliani going after you know the
we build the wall people Lawrence going
after parents and calling them domestic
terrorists not just having tabletop
exercises at the Aspen Institute in
preparation of the 2020 election having
standing meetings at Twitter with yoel
Roth demanding censorship going
preemptively to Mark Zuckerberg and
doing a shake down saying that hey there
might be some Russian disinformation
that you might have to censor
Christopher Wray was the architect of
all of this and continues to be it so
the question is do we actually still
have
a a semblance of a representative
government in some senses yes in some
senses no and why is that you know the
lack of accountability the media
presents towards the administrative
state is glaring and I'll prove it to
you I had to watch some CBS or NBC uh
for or some stupid like why we need to
be supporting Ukraine war type thing and
they were saying okay we're coming up on
like the year and a half mark and they
said you know the Russian government is
so tyrannical because they put their
political dissidents in prison
and they put journalists in prison it's
like oh really I mean like raiding James
O'Keefe's home
or like trying to put Donald Trump in
200 years in prison like yeah I don't
know a government that would do such a
thing as that like everything that we
criticize the Russian government for the
Kremlin our government is doing times 10
against our own political dissidents and
so why is this
I blame Republicans for a lot of this
Lindsey Graham and a lot of people post
911 they they transform the FBI from a
law enforcement agency into an
intelligence agency and those are two
distinctly different things law
enforcement agency does not preemptively
try to monitor or surveil or spy on
American citizens to try to find a crime
a law enforcement agency follows leads
to then hold people accountable if
you're doing something illegal let's go
all the way back J Edgar Hoover was a
total freak by the way the FBI never
should have been formed as it was It was
supposed to stop Interstate Bank
trafficking and maybe human smuggling
and so post 911 who did this Bob Mueller
was head of the FBI when this ended up
happening he made the switch and George
W bush and Dick Cheney and Lindsey
Graham and Denny hassert and everyone
Mitch McConnell every one of these
neocons because of the panic of 911
Republican voters unfortunately were
largely in support of giving away are
god-given civil liberties and freedoms
to Department of Homeland Security cisa
FBI because we were afraid of radical
Islamic terrorism guess what that was a
real thing but we cert we soon realized
there was a supply and demand problem
with radical Islamic terrorism there
just wasn't that much in the American
Homeland and so then all of a sudden
they started twiddling their thumbs and
they have these tens of billions of
dollars of budgets Barack Obama becomes
president and a whisper campaign starts
and says huh what if the real terrorism
is white Christian nationalists in Iowa
what if the real terrorists are the
people that are the Q Anon extremist and
what is now turned in the FBI from what
was once trying to be a preventative
measure to stop 911 from happening is
now a massive
50 to 70 billion dollar agency that we
know of it's probably even bigger than
that that is targeted against half the
country and their values don't believe
me the FBI is infiltrating Latin Mass
literally they're going into Catholic
Latin Masses because they're considered
to be you can look up that story and it
whistleblower after whistleblower says
the FBI currently has undercover agents
going to Catholic Latin mess that we
Patrick I go around the country and
people ask me Charlie when are we going
to become the Soviet Union like news
flash our government has become the
Soviet Union this is exactly how the
secret police under Stalin operated and
Christopher Wray is the grand Meister of
this and the think about how silly this
is if the House of Representatives were
to hold him in contempt where does that
contempt charge go to him so he would
have to go indict himself
so how do you how do you fix this I
fully support the calls to break up and
abolish the FBI and turn it into 10 or
12 different microagencies against
legitimate like child sex trafficking or
human smuggling or Bank crimes 90 of
what the FBI does right now is
politically driven investigations and
surveillance and not to mention the fisa
you can look up the other article the
the the the the amount of fisa abuse
f-i-s-a what's it a million Charlie it
was like a million yeah exactly right
that legalized us that's right if you go
to there was a recent five I think it
was the statement of either Michael
Horowitz or something there was a recent
report that shows that a million times
they broke the law so Patrick you and I
don't break the law we go to jail unless
we're Hunter Biden or we're you know
Untouchable what happens when the
government breaks the law
yeah nothing Charlie FBA raises and
private jets and bigger buildings yeah
FBI Christopher Ray
appointed by Trump in 2017. this is a
this is a legitimate Point yeah I mean
that's the point how much do you think
Trump regrets being the person that
tapped Rey to be the FBI director look I
can't I can't speak for his level of
regret I I think there's a fair amount
of Fury
because now the very people he put into
office are now trying to put him in
prison for 200 years think about that
for a second right I mean some people
get lost in the Nuance right there the
guy that he picked yes to be the
director of the FBI is now the guy
that's trying to put Trump in prison
think about that that's like you picking
the new CFO of PHP and now he's trying
to use serp you to take your job put you
in prison so so this there's a lot of
reasons why the Personnel of the Trump
White House was as even Rush Limbaugh
would say puzzling yeah and Russia
especially he never said something
negative about Trump yeah he said uh
puzzling like what a rush term right and
this is why and it goes back to why they
hate Trump so much why they have to
throw him in prison why they're doing
all this is he was not supposed to win
no one thought he was gonna win there
was no prep there was no transition team
so you go from a guy that's on one
percent probability meter on the New
York Times website all of a sudden
president-elect so all of us out of
nowhere who comes in the the people the
worst people come in right pulled right
in the Trump Tower the next day you had
people taking the 6 a.m flight out of
Washington DC flattering Trump being
like these people are going to be
amazing in your white house they were
sleeper cells for the shadow government
how much of it is on Trump and I'm not
here to like but hear me out at this
point he's making a post I want to hear
what he was going to say I don't think
he was done you were saying how much of
this is under sleeper uh uh yeah look I
I think we could all Monday Morning
Quarterback I think he fully
acknowledges that he could have made
better Personnel Selections in certain
places
I I will say this is that he was so
deceived by the people closest to him I
mean how many people do we have to go
through from John Bolton to Kelly to
Omarosa that turned into like Brutus
Cassius Judas right it was like how many
Brutus caches Judas archetypes were
trolling around that place look I I
you're not going to get me to say
something negative about like Trump how
much is that on Trump or not I think it
needs to be the number one place of
improvement because from Berks to fauci
those people never should have been
around the world this isn't a gotcha hey
Charlie I'm just not honest I'm actually
trying to be constructive here to be
honest with you
because he marketed himself as I'm gonna
hire the best people I'm gonna have the
best people around me that was his
selling point
how much has he learned and if he is the
the next president United States which
he can who's he going to hire yeah that
it this doesn't happen again so
thankfully there's a guy named John
mcentee he's publicly working on this he
was the best guy in the white house he
got so much done he was Trump's body guy
and kind of became de facto Personnel
Chief and he's already putting it
together in conjunction with the
Heritage Foundation they're working on
this
I'm not that interested in that because
that's just not my skill set I mean
we're happy to send resumes and stuff I
just want to win because we don't win
then who cares about your transition
project but the number one by the way
the number one policy objection that the
base has to Donald Trump was his
Personnel right and but think about it
you're a once in a 100 Year wrecking
ball that was once you go from New York
City developer and talk show personality
cable personality the president United
States like you don't have a Tickler
file of personnel like go run the
department of interior right right and
he wasn't wrong like when he ran his
businesses in New York he did have the
best people but he was able to fire them
on demand and they were motivated by one
thing profit so he was operating under a
system where that people wanted to get
paychecks they wanted to get bonus
that's not how DC works at all it's not
a profit system it's patronage
it's access
its favors it's one-off deals it's
deceit so in markets you know this
Patrick from building an unbelievably
successful business markets you you
cannot lie in a market in the sense of
either make money or you don't make
money in DC it's nothing but lying House
of Cards and by the way that is 100 how
it operates it's blackmail it's backroom
deals and here he is he's like what the
hell is this like let's just build the
wall and then people are leaking on him
right people are talking negatively
about him and not to mention again some
people don't like it when they say oh
Trump is always the victim and all this
stop it you had within a week the FBI
with Peter strzok in the White House
illegally entrapping the National
Security advisor that is in clearest
terms the administrative state that was
going after the will of The Sovereign
people what played out in the first
Trump term from the first impeachment
was which was in illegally listened to
phone call we forget it was Eric Schmidt
shamarella who leaked a national
security phone call who did Trump had
that call with zielinski people forget
that was Donald Trump's call with
zelenski that Eric shimarella was
illegally leaked how about the second
impeachment was January 6 separate issue
but kovid lockdowns fauci's lies Burks
lies fear-mongering death tolls on TV
CNN everyone is going to die you know
Lance at study it's gonna wipe out 30 of
the population you know hydroxychloric
and Ivermectin vitamin D levels IV can't
talk about any of that stuff social
media censorship Donald Trump owns
shares in Ivermectin it's a horse drug
go after Joe Rogan I mean has anyone
ever had that kind of
multi-institutional attack at him and
he's still only I use the word loss very
carefully he was not president by 8 000
votes in Arizona like 10 000 votes in
Arizona 12 000 in Georgia and 20 000 in
Wisconsin that's remarkable they they're
afraid they can't do 2020 again and that
in 2024 apps and indictments or other
interference this guy actually might be
president again because they're right he
might that's a scary thought for them if
that happens no it's terrifying this is
why Jack Smith is acting like he's a
Nazi war criminal right you remember
when the the day when Trump won and beat
Hillary and everybody's looked at video
you know the one main video Everybody
crying the girls crying I mean I'm sorry
I found joy in that I'm sure you do they
go to sleep but but I have a feeling
it's gonna be that time that times 10 if
it happens in 24 but Rob can you can you
pull up the story on California Vinnie
you were talking about the story you
know which one I'm talking about
California Assembly committee black uh
blocks bill that could have sent human
traffickers to kids of kids to prison
for life and if you go a little lower
you know got it the Golden State lower
house committee Senate bill 14 which
would make human trafficking for
children a serious felony the serious
felony charges under California law
currently include murder rape and any
other crime which may incur in the death
penalty or life sentence in the state
prison however instead of upping the NT
on child traffickers the California
Assembly Public Safety Committee new the
measure on Tuesday how Wild is that and
and they don't just nuke it on any week
they nuke it on the week of the movie
sound of Freedom coming out that beats
uh Harrison Ford's movie Indiana Jones
and I was like ah you know it's just a
you know it's a not a real story it's
just a bunch of different things
inaccurate facts what what is like what
is a Newsome thinking when stuff like
this is passing in his state how do you
sell this how do you sell this to
parents I don't think he cares because
California is so ridiculously Democrat
that he's never going to be held
accountable but I mean you know Patrick
you have really broad-based appeal I
encourage the next Democrat you have on
the show just like ask them a very
simple question which is like I know you
hate Trump I know you have to
reflexively oppose everything the
American right focus is on right like
everything but do you really have to do
that when it comes to child sex
trafficking like can you check your like
pathological
type opposition to all things right wing
and just maybe like just lay down in
your arms for I don't know one issue
like just one issue yeah can you just
like take it easy I mean Rolling Stone
Guardian Q Anon adjacent film seducing
America that was the Rolling Stone
headline that might have been the
guardian or the rolling stone guardian
had two yeah but that was the time
miles CLE for Rolling yeah and so maybe
you could just like take an afternoon
off I mean you guys love doing weed a
lot like why don't you just like smoke
weed and like take like this is not a
necessary article for you to publish
right sound of freedom is a superhero
movie for dads with brain worms
okay that's rollingstone.com first of
all it's a true story it's a heroic
story It's A Beautiful film it's really
successful maybe we could all agree that
okay we have different politics but I
don't know like moving children across
state lines and prostituting them for
rape and for money is probably evil like
no you're queuing on
well hold on like do you understand what
you're doing I mean can you break out of
your muscle memory automatic opposition
that if someone on the right says
something I must oppose it I try my best
to do this right to not do this right if
I see something on the left like if
Bobby Kennedy says something I like I'm
gonna speak out I encourage everyone in
the audience regardless of your politics
this right here is the most destructive
operating behavior in the entire country
and people on the right do it it's bad
people on the left people on the right
don't do it as much they just don't
because I I think they tend to be more
intellectually honest because they have
to constantly prove their their stances
and beliefs but this right here what
what does this accomplish where you're
bashing a movie that eight years ago
Patrick ten years ago the country that
we used to have 10 years ago people be
like oh cool film let's go bring our
families but now it instantly has to
politicize things and people say oh
Charlie why are we so divided because
Rolling Stone politicizes things that
should have widespread agreement unless
you're a pedophile on unless you are a
pedophile and I'm not suggesting this
author is but unless you are a pedophile
you should probably support sound of
Freedom Charlie you're one million
percent right in what you're saying and
I saw the movie last night you saw it a
week ago less than a week ago you
recognized I just saw it we talked about
this the other day with Lauren Chen yeah
uh and I there's probably someone up on
an upcoming podcast possibly this
weekend that we can even bring this up
to
um but you're absolutely right I'm in
downtown Miami not exactly far right
wing in Omega country not exactly far
left either Cuban Community Republican
great beautiful very purple City here in
Miami terrific place all sorts of shapes
and colors are at the movie everyone
Jaws dropped yeah holy [__] so if I
didn't know about the headlines ahead of
time now that I'm seeing these headlines
as just a reasonable moderate person I'm
like what the [__] are they thinking
what is dad with brain worms
it's a movie of vilified disgusting vile
people and
yes and selling them in to sexual
slavery period full stop yes it's not a
political agenda nothing and so but
Rolling Stone is like attacking us as
dads with brain worms look at the Q a
non-tinge do you know who that Miles
Cleves he's a weirdo by the way they
they showed up photos of us of his uh of
his profile but you know you know what's
crazy in this situation the left doesn't
care do you know who does care Charlie
criminals like people that are in jail
like Larry Nasser just got stabbed six
times the ex gymnastics guy these people
don't give a [__] but criminals who are
in there for you know beating people up
or or burglary they find your ass and
they help hold your account and that
goes to show exactly what Aristotle
argued which that there's a hierarchy to
the good and there's a hierarchy to the
bad right and even if someone's like in
jail for embezzling money or like they
even know the most vile scum are the
pedophiles or traffickers so you think
about it like you make a really
interesting point the prisoners again
I'm not defending the stabbing
he has the scum of the earth and I
believe he'll go into the fire of Hell
unless he repents in front of Jesus
Christ Our Lord and Savior I really
believe that but like even they are like
no no yeah like okay I might have I
don't know shot up like a drive-by
shooting or like rob the bank rob the
bank but don't mess with the kids no yup
so let me the morality of a prison gang
is clear in the morality of Rolling
Stone yes brilliant and I've heard that
I've heard that multiple times from
people who I know that is like the
strongest point of her they'll kill you
if they find out that's the reason
you're in jail not murder you're dead no
you're dead not criminal activity no
none of that they find out that you're
raping children they will come for you
in prison imagine you know what you know
what the story was uh Charlie that he
Larry Nasser was in the prison and
Wimbledon they wanted to watch Wimbledon
he's like let's put on the women's and
the guy stab the [__] out of them so I
salute that guy I don't care he got to
get paid I don't support the you know
vigilante stabbing of people in prisons
however I will say this prisons are I
don't know how deep is one of those
prisons are super interesting pictures
into the state of nature right so we're
always asking like what are people like
in their natural habitat so what does
prison have well you don't have to work
you have all your meals provided for you
you have room and board so what happens
in prison people naturally Associated
people who look like them so we're
naturally tribal people right you
naturally form into communities where
you other the other people that's also
for survival no no of course it is but
it also just happens without any sort of
central plan right whites with white
hispanic Hispanics blacks with blacks
I'm not defending it it's just
interesting from an opposite
observational standpoint but also that
there's a there's a moral code that
comes in where even the people who are
locked up for life that have done things
that we would consider to be against
Civil Society standards they say that in
the state of nature you do not need to
go to Harvard to know you don't need to
go to Stanford to know that raping
children is evil even the bad people
know that is what you're saying like
even in the state of nature like reduce
down the person that you and I would be
like okay like like you shouldn't have
robbed those 30 cars like or whatever
you did right they then they have a line
that thou shall not okay I love that
what a point right when you think about
that like listen there's a there's a
certain moral code you did that no
problem everybody gangs up against
everybody but that in the state of
nature what it goes to show is that
there's something fundamental in our
soul that says children are off limits
and yet Rolling Stone does not subscribe
to that you're saying there's a
hierarchy of evil and that's the top of
the list I I believe in grade the better
word is gradations right gradations of
sins that that for example stealing a
pencil is nowhere near raping a child I
guess different universes I believe that
epistemological and theologically and
religiously and I think we all agree
that morally but what's I just I just
want to re-emphasize the point that the
prison gang is thinking more clearly in
terms of good or evil or right and wrong
than the mainstream and by the way and
if it's the male sex offenders look how
they're wired look at these guys this is
a telegraph story male sex offenders
faking trans ident entities to to move
to women's prison brilliant okay
research backed by Ministry of Justice
suggests that male sex offenders are
pretending to be transgender in order to
be transferred to women's prisons
inmates who fake transition exceed as a
way to lower their risk and secure a
place in female prison State there were
168 legally male trans women prisoners
in England and Wales with only six in
women's prisons and the remainder in
men's prisons men jailed for sexual
offenses are twice as likely to identify
as trans women who then those jailed for
other types of offenses the ministry of
justice has introduced stricter rulers
rules after the controversy surrounding
the placement of a transgender convict
convicted of raping two women in an
all-female prison the study reveals
concerns about fakers posing a threat to
reputation of genuine transgender
prisons prisoners and limit resources
available in custody you know what this
is bad policies eventually get exposed
hypocrisy gets exposed and now they have
to sit there and try to argue and defend
this and they can't How You Gonna defend
this you can't defend an argument like
this what do you think about when you
hear a story like this oh I mean look I
have very strong opinions on the trans
thing but it's not going to stop right I
mean so of course they're going to fail
well first of all the headline says male
sex offenders faking trans identities
all trans identities are fake so I don't
understand what you mean faking like
it's all fake you're not you're not
you're not what you wish to be you are
what you are okay such a good point so
but yeah I mean so they're trying I mean
this this old idea used to be kind of a
joke right of oh yeah I would be want to
become a woman so I could go in the
female locker room well it's not a joke
it's not policy and this is a social
contagion I don't fall under this and
you guys obviously don't I hope not
either which is are you going to
reaccommodate all of society for
people's deep-seated mental problems no
that's a really bad idea you should not
change Customs you should not change
rules you should not change protections
of the innocent or women because people
are having
issues with their own existence or their
own identity period And yet we're seeing
that not just in prisons but in sports
and in schools and so you could tell a
lot by a society about what do people do
with power
okay so if you're in charge of a society
do you use that power to protect people
that are not as strong as you yeah or do
you use that power to then terrorize
people that are not as strong as you
almost every society that has ever
existed uses power for tyranny or
authoritarian means the West was built
on this idea that we are going to
intervene to protect those that can't
protect themselves it's a profound idea
it's a Christian idea right that I care
about my neighbor treat you know love
your neighbor as yourself Leviticus 19
Jesus said you could you the two most
important things love the Lord your God
with all your heart soul strength and
mind and then treat love your neighbor
as yourself that teaching built the West
love your neighbor as yourself therefore
if there's someone for example in a
wheelchair
and somebody goes by and just like
throws them onto the street you should
go to jail for that like that but you
look at it through a darwinistic secular
lens why why not what's wrong with that
survival the fittest like no you should
not be able to use your power to exploit
harm damage somebody that does not have
the same same strength as you in fact
it's morally incumbent on the people who
do have the strength I use strength as a
broad term not just physical strength
but I do mean it in this sense and yes
men are stronger than women there are
some women that are stronger than men
but generally bone density testosterone
muscle mass like we really have to prove
this right now so don't be surprised
when male predators that have deep
seated mental problems want to go into
women's prisons to rape them
and get them pregnant there was there
was an issue a couple months ago they
were getting them pregnant but it's just
like this I mean again we live in Narnia
in some ways like this really weird
existence where five years ago Patrick
when you and I sat down at Turning Point
USA's young women's Leadership Summit I
had like these feminazis were screaming
in my ear about oh my gosh men are
around
always wanted to rape me and Kavanaugh's
a gang rapist and everyone's Harvey
Weinstein and five years later they're
like but if Harvey Weinstein identifies
as a woman progress yeah but he's great
here's a question for everybody here so
all of us here so you know how you just
said five years ago trans wasn't a thing
right and we're not talking about it but
it wasn't what it is it's not what it is
today right okay so you know women's
sports you saw can you pull up the
picture about the uh what was it the the
Netherlands woman uh oh yeah yeah no
that's correct Miss Netherlands Miss
Netherlands on who she beat out like who
she be you're at a nightclub you got two
choices you're 24 years old you're
single how dark is it who are you
picking how dark is the club can you get
the pictures of the two girls right next
to each other I don't know if you have
that or not by the way I'm loving that
I'm seeing this for the first time
on my Instagram okay Instagram yeah I
have the contract that's harvested
that's her smiling with getting the
crown that's the man not her that's oh
my bad I apologize that's the guy that
just won Miss Vinnie can't even tell bro
sorry bro so so Rob why don't you just
go to his Instagram I'm gonna go pull it
up because you have to see this okay
yeah it's on my Instagram I did a
picture by picture that's the one you
want to show you want to show the one
that's the picture by picture
Netherlands is woke huh yeah Netherlands
went for it are you shorts on your
Instagram or it's on your Twitter scroll
down uh that see the beauty button and
then I believe it's two pictures in a
row I could be wrong oh you gotta see if
you got it or not because you guys can
open it you open it in a new tab
it usually yeah you're here Rob I'll
just text and you never would have
thought like another list I haven't gone
for it huh they're part of the EU bro
just tell me when you got it I'm gonna
text it do you see the picture the guy
on the left yeah try the next one try
the next photo
what check this out oh my God the one to
the left wins the girl on the right who
are the judges that's the real question
so you're at a nightclub yeah the two
ones to your left once to your right
Vinnie how many drinks one says to you
how many drinks one says to you yeah
hello Vinnie the other one says to you
hi Jenny
which one are you going to be picking do
you realize the guy to the left wins
Miss Netherlands how many Long Island
icedes have I had it doesn't matter how
many years virgin daiquiri whatever
you're gonna have no the girl on the
right is unacceptable it's unbelievable
unbelievable can we punch in on the
number one the girl on the right it's
beautiful absolutely gorgeous if you're
ever come to South Beach Florida
absolutely gorgeous punch it on the left
because it's a sort of a different uh
perspective on the picture can you punch
in Rob
while we're talking try to find a
picture that zoomed in a little bit more
to see though just let's see the atoms
when you're thinking about that when
you're going through this rub you find
it but here's what I want you to think
about you know some ideas uh create
momentum and then it's short-lived and
it disappears or some toys or some games
or some whatever right this happens all
the time hey remember in New York they
used to do the punch uh the person and
then you would run away oh yeah yeah the
knocking album Zoom in a little bit more
zoom in a little bit but what's the I'm
sorry can I interrupt you yeah go for it
look at the women applauding and I have
a whole theory on this
tell us well look Andrew Tate talks
about this frequently by the way your
interview was great I didn't watch all
five hours but you've done a great job
Patrick congratulations to you covering
all that is that men are disagreeable by
Nature we are the ones that say no
women are agreeable by Nature they want
to be liked yeah that right there is a
feminine culture gone awry agreeableness
by all means agreeableness even to allow
men to metaphorically rape our
competitions this is a metaphorical rape
of Miss Netherlands is what it is I am a
man and I'm forcibly inserting myself
without consent into your competition
I'm sorry to be so graphic but that's
what this is and they're like oh yeah
progress
applauding
but imagine for a second if it was an
all-male competition put up with that
crap the guys in the back would be like
what the what's going on
who are you yeah little punk because
this is why when a society goes to
feminine it can also become too
tyrannical but how long is this Gonna
Last so again go back to it listen the
question I'm asking is remember that one
thing you stood on it and you would go
you would spin whatever that thing was
that one uh wheel thing what was that
question by the way for about three
years five years that thing was hot
right Paul Blart Mall Cop we didn't talk
about a lot of things trendy products
that disappeared after two three four
five years that's right yeah and you're
no longer using it vaccines how long how
long how long is this gonna go before
they themselves women like you know what
it's gonna take it's gonna take a
feminist girl from the left who's a
hardcore liberal to come out and say
guys this is too much because let me
tell you what happened to my daughter
I'm not with it so I um
it will only last as long as we allow it
to last because it is a pathogen of evil
and we must be intolerant of this crap
there should be no openness to this
period but I'm not as bullish on it
ending soon because unlike the Segway
this is supported by the CDC
this is supported by and by the way
vastly billions of dollars be made by
Pfizer astrogenica moderna not just on
the surgery but on the annuities of
other drugs that will be made this is a
cash cow for the most powerful companies
in the world you can look up the map and
there used to be two
two gender clinics 40 years ago in the
Western World now there are well over
five to six hundred in America alone you
could fact check me on this but I
believe it's at least five or six
hundred probably grew by five just us
sitting here yes be and by the way if
you if you look at
yeah the thought in the 60s or 70s there
were some and then there are none some I
don't know what the number is now you
can look it up
it's for at least five or six hundred
Nationwide so there's a whole cottage
industry Patrick but here's the biggest
problem is the social contagion it's
like the lab leak from Wuhan right it's
out and so how do we actually inoculate
ourselves against it that the the the
the transmission is through Tick Tock
where they are preying on young girls
that have puberty anxiety that are
misdiagnosing their puberty anxiety for
gender dysphoria and then they go into a
predatory pediatric pediatric
environment where the questions are all
wrong the questions are well do you
think you're a man would you like to
talk to somebody about whether you're a
man instead of I understand you're
having anxiety about where you're at
let's just take pause and allow yourself
to develop puberty is actually the
solution here
it's not the problem what do they do
they give them puberty blockers they
slow down the thing that actually once
it comes to completion and your hormones
balance and you're like okay my estrogen
and testosterone levels naturally kind
of even out
then we're we're we're clear how long
Patrick I have no idea but we as clear
courageous Americans need to stand up
against this and it is tyrannical in
nature that's got to be an outdated map
and there was one more research you said
Tick Tock and what a great uh segue just
of how China has just been owning our
asses they obviously own Tick Tock
they're infiltr they've already done it
they're training their kid they train
their kindergarten kids for for for
combat I'm not even joking they put them
in a war boot camps they spy China's
just it's not a gun shooting War it's a
slowly infiltrating us and that would
that's one of the main that's one of the
main ones is that the trans and making
men you also said that you're not
bullish on basically the stopping the
the biggest thing is I am okay and I'll
tell you guys here in a minute yeah
but I want you to do well I just want to
I want to give you Kudos because you
just did a whole
episode on this the dark history of the
LGBT right that's the map I'm sorry just
keep going all good but the key word in
that is the T guys you know nobody's got
a problem with the L's the G's the B the
t is where all right what's happening
right now that's a totally different
agenda but by the way you said that 20
percent
of gen Z that's what we're talking about
now future of America yeah it's not part
We're not gonna work guys well it's not
gonna work it's trending in the wrong
way by the way we can we can argue this
is why we have a debate and you know we
point out leaks in our argument your
argument and we have but we have a good
time with this so can you go to uh go to
the other one I sent you I just sent you
two links in the email if you can pull
up one of them one of them that
validates his is the one from Pentagon
if you can pull that up uh uh I don't
know if you have it or not okay so the
one from Pentagon shows this is from
military.com so this is not a website
that is a second party third party or
blogger or any of that stuff it's
military.com says here's how much the
Pentagon has spent so far to to treat
transgender troops the military you and
I are paying for this okay okay here's
how much it's spent okay so again this
is what website military.com the
Pentagon has spent the Pentagon has
spent 15 million dollars in the past
five years to treat 1892 trans gender
troops including 11.5 million for
Psychotherapy and 3.1 million for
surgeries according to defense
department data provided to military.com
and then you can see up the 243 gender
resigning surgeries performed on a
military personnel since 2016. 50 of
them wasn't 16.
193 occurred from January 1st 29 2018 to
2019 and then two years after president
Donald Trump announced via Twitter he
would bar transgender individuals from
serving the military okay so now you see
this you're like wait a minute I paid
this much yeah you taxpayer you paid for
it now one argument I'll make to you how
dumb this is I want you to think about
this I want you to think you're the
enemy and the enemy ji Putin gets a
report hey uh sir I have a report to
show you deeply concerning what's that
it's a massive threat America has a new
secret weapon on how they're going to
take us down what's that do they have a
new name six no no is it a new nuclear
no they're investing in transgender
surgeries what and these guys are a like
they're even better than Navy Seals no
way we think Putin's in there saying
that's exactly what's going on with
America now
watch this who supported kids staying
home and not going to school who
supported it who supported
and general surgeon Vivek comes out
saying no we need to stay home and all
this other stuff here's what we need to
do because we can't risk the lives of
all these elderly perfect give the other
article that I just texted to you this
is new by the look what website it is go
to what website it is it's important to
show the website all the way at the top
this is the US Department of Health and
Human Services this is who came to our
office when covet happened if you
remember in Dallas and in Dallas they
wanted to find us they said you guys
covered all the things because Ian did a
great job back then so go back to the
article on the bottom and see what
happens this is May 3rd put the date on
when it is at the top so they can see it
May 3rd 2023. new Surgeon General
advisory raises alarm about the
devastating impact of the epidemic of
loneliness and isolation in the United
States
Sherlock you pulled this off right so
here's the point this is what's going to
happen wait till one of their daughters
gets violated by a transgender man and
it's deep in their house
and then they're going to realize guys I
don't give a fly-in you know what this
just crossed the line This is insanity
and then they're going to unify and come
together and say we have to create a
league Trends you want to compete
against each other go ahead and compete
against each other but the Neville level
of
like you know one of the questions I
want to ask uh one of our friends that's
coming on next Saturday when I've been
exchanging no one's going to believe
that discussion this Saturday next
Saturday oh next Saturday gotcha I can't
wait to have this conversation with them
the guy actually really like and it's a
probably one of the top five biggest
liberal TV show hosts out there I'm
excited about having them on okay so
you're gonna know his name you know you
know what the question is going to be
here's what the question is going to be
the question is going to be what do we
have in common
what do Republicans and OG Democrats
Kennedy Democrats Clinton Democrats now
I'm not talking biting Democrats what do
Clinton Democrats and JFK Democrats have
in common with Republicans what is it
what do we have I I bet there is so many
things we agree on is it fair to say
that you want to make sure your kids are
protected yes I do too great is it fair
to say that you want to be able to go to
any church you want to go to if you're
an atheist no problem you're a
Scientologist no problem you're
Christian Muslim go for it practice
whatever you you agree that I do too
right is it fair to say that you don't
want to pay so much taxes that the
incentive goes away for your kids to
want to go build a business when they
have their dreams because yeah I'm with
that okay is it fair that we won't want
the country to be safe I do maybe you
don't want to spend as much money maybe
I don't want to spend that much money
maybe but we both agree yes how about
the transgender stuff can I ask why
We can't agree on this you know I'm
watching a video of Serena Williams
we've all seen it she's on David
Letterman he's trying to get her to say
you know she says no Andy Murray called
me and said let's play a match together
and Serena says honestly Andy I don't
want to play against you because it'll
be a five minute match he'll beat me six
nothing six nothing it won't even be
close I don't want to compete against
man because I lose I want to compete
against women it's not even fair and
then David Letterman and the audience is
quiet because you know which and by the
way she's a liberal her husband Armenian
guy he's a liberal they're not
Republicans but she's saying logic
eventually this is the one if you want
to play this and look how uncomfortable
he gets everyone's seen it here can you
make it bigger and impressive Watch What
Happens here with her well actually it's
funny because Andy Murray he oh he was
been joking about
um myself and him playing a match and
I'm like Andy seriously like are you
kidding me because for me tennis and
men's tennis and women's sins are
completely almost two separates she's a
Democrat I'm like if I were to pay
6060 and five to six minutes maybe 10
minutes because no it's true it's true
completely no one's reacting that's a
completely different word the men are a
lot faster and me and um they they get
they serve harder they hit hard it's
just a different game and I love to play
women's tennis and I I only want to play
girls I don't want to be embarrassed I
would not do it I wouldn't do a Billie
Jean any justice so Andy's stop it yeah
we're not gonna I'm not gonna let you
kill me okay I'm with you when it comes
oh I'm with you oh okay David you sure
your wits is old though yeah no no it is
it's ten years old
it's not the point though yeah she would
say the same thing today 100 she would
say the same thing today because common
sense and logic eventually prevails
because eventually certain communities
like one of the things you said it's so
powerful the world the word I've been uh
uh dealing with lately for myself is
tolerance and intolerance you know the
whole thing about you know we we
Christian you know to me three
communities are ruining America it's
very easy for me it's the scared and
lazy Republicans okay sure you're not
buying Time Magazine you're not buying
you know any of the stuff that's
available you're not buying any of these
media companies while they're buying so
number one is scared on lazy Republicans
number two is tolerant Christians yes
and number three is do your thing
Libertarians I think those three
communities are ruining America but
logic and Common Sense comes out and
Democrats say she doesn't exempts I'm
kind of on the same page with you there
so maybe it's America over my political
party eventually I think enough people
are going to say America over my
political party yeah and I I agree so
whether I'm bearish or the the trans
thing is unique because it's
fundamentally predatory on anxiety
that's not going to go away with young
teenagers and we have now trained
hundreds of thousands of teachers to
advance the social contagion 40 of all
brown kids 38 of all students at Brown
University identifies
lgbtqia Plus
okay 38 this is the gayest generation in
history let's just talk you could have
your own opinions on the gay thing I
Believe In traditional marriage
obviously but you're how are you going
to like repopulate the species if 40 of
your
people are or 38 are gay yeah 38 at
Brown University wow are gay 38 this is
a social contagion so it is accelerating
it's not slowing down but Patrick you're
right it could end up slowing down but
it requires a mindset shift it requires
decent Ordinary People to say okay I
grew up with the temperament of Live and
Let Live I'm not going to allow you to
have this trans zealotry continue the
spread across the country this is a war
on reality what you just saw with Serena
Williams and David Letterman was a
50-second refreshing clip of reality the
the entire project of post-modernism
rejects reality it's you can be whatever
you want to be as you want to be it take
chemicals wage war on your own natural
design you get to decide your own
existence you can just think it in your
mind you don't even take chemicals no
that's exactly right and I'm a
billionaire guys I just yeah
it really is this simple and I I don't
mean to like trivialize this the New
Divide and America is team reality
against insane neurotic people yes it's
that simple if you are on team reality
Bobby Kennedy I think he's great he
lives on team reality okay he lived he
he the biggest crime that Bobby Kennedy
Jr has committed is the crime of
noticing
oh wait why do so many people love
autism why is our air like harder to
breathe like why are testosterone rates
down oh he's a q Anon conspiracy
theorist far right wing extremist
Kennedy Democrat because he commits the
crime of noticing noticing is the first
step to live in reality
and saying something then speaking the
truth which we believe in the Christian
tradition is the logos right so it's
very simple the West used 99 of people
in the west used to believe in this
regardless of your religious affiliation
I'm going to notice what's happening
around me I'm gonna say what's happening
around me and then we can have a
discussion of whether or not that should
continue now you're not even allowed to
notice it now it's you're a bigot you're
a terrible person for even mentioning
the Injustice that is so obviously
happening around you yeah absolute truth
and so by the way have you seen the
Gallup poll have you seen the Gallup
poll that shows in America I don't know
if I'm asking Brandon to say this
because this video that we did on lgbtq
if you've not seen this video let me
tell you it's great the amount of emails
and stuff I got from people who are
negative but 95 was positive good saying
I didn't even know this data you know
what was one of the most interesting uh
data data points uh Brian if you can
send it to me if you don't it's all good
you have it in your notes it went not
this one it's another one he didn't send
you the right one this this one
everyone's seen there was one that we
had that showed in 1979 they asked it's
a Gallup poll they asked Americans what
percentage of gays are they gay because
they're born that way versus their
environment you know what percentage of
Americans in 1979 said you're born gay
versus environment less than 15 probably
exactly 13 interesting you're right
there right you know what the number is
today here I got the Galloping I want to
show you probably 65
I want to say it's 49 I want to say
that's lower than I thought yeah you
have to see this Gallup by the way this
link to this Gallup poll I two things I
recommend go watch that lgbtq video and
two keep this Gallup poll we're about to
put put it in the comment section so
people can also have a drop I'm texting
it to you if you can pull it up because
it's different versus when somebody says
it versus you see it gallup.com that
says what this is and the the one I want
you to go to where it says I'm going to
listen to regardless okay go all the way
to the bottom that says what percentage
of people were born gay versus their
environment okay it's all the way I
think at the bottom if you can find this
by the way Gallup pretty credible
polling very incredible Source yeah so
not far right not far left they've also
shown that the country's moving center
right that's another poll they've done
recently which is really by the way he's
right and you know what else they found
out which was kind of weird this whole
thing about born gay versus not born gay
there was another thing that they said
about where we were at back in the days
on allowing gays to adopt children this
one produced the biggest controversy on
the questions back in 1977 it was only
14 they said they should today it's 75
if you go all the way to the bottom and
type in adopt if you just control F
adopt it'll show up if you just want to
type in there you go look at that 1977
14 said they should 77 percent no they
should not but in 2019 it's 75 percent
they should converted it's inverted okay
and then you have the other 13 that said
they were born or they were not born the
whole point is
and then there was another data that
came out with Gallup which was very
interesting the whole about black
liberals versus white liberals I don't
know if you've seen this one no but I
black liberals tend to be more socially
conservative than white liberals by by a
mile even white conservatives they're
more socially Conservative then black so
so Republicans black liberals white
liberals just think about those three
okay same question what percentage of
gays are born gay versus you know their
environment okay yeah culture versus
nurture Republicans say no it's your
environment you're not born gay okay
white liberals 72 said you're born that
way you know what black liberals was 30
I believe it they were 21 away from
Republicans and 42 percent away from
White liberals so I think there's and
then by the way when you look at the
Muslim Community and you know what
percentage of Muslims vote the liberal
do you know what percentage the Muslims
80 70 plus percent vote liberal but by
the way here's the data for you very
interesting this is something for you to
be considering within Turning Point USA
to think about check that admit terms do
you know from 2018 midterms to 2022
midterms watch this 2018 midterms to
2022 midterm specifically Muslims okay
2018 midterms only 17 percent voted
Republican let me say it again 2018
midterms only 17 voted Republican do you
know what it was in 2022 28 oh wow guys
that's 11 in four years here's what is
happening that that's profound that's
profound here's what's happened and by
the way we'll send you that data here's
what's happened which is exciting this
is what I love that's happened that's
exciting which is kind of awkward it's a
very awkward very weird but it's
exciting okay
what would happen to liberals you ready
for this one by the way we know why
Muslims don't vote conservative because
conservatives are pro-israel so it's
kind of like something that stand with
them so they're kind of like but in
every issue abortion Muslims have the
lowest percentage of divorces lowest
percentage of divorces how do you feel
about abortion how they feel about lgbtq
all of that stuff Muslims have a
conservative belief but Democrats have
won over the Muslim vote as well as the
black vote because of you know certain
positions right what if conservatives
are able to win
black liberals and what if conservatives
are able to win Muslims and what if
Muslims and Christians come together and
say look let's set aside Prophet
Muhammad and Jesus we know what you
believe in we know what we believe in
but listen when it comes unto these
issues with family let's unite do you
know how scary it would be if a
Republican strategist behind closed
doors brought the 10 biggest influencers
and said we have to make a better
argument to Muslims because Republicans
have always been what no no no it's the
farm to Muslims no no stiff arm to
Muslims there's a lot of Muslims that
are waiting to convert to Republican
Republicans are not doing a good job
winning them over the argument makes
sense for Muslims to be Republican but
Republicans are doing a terrible job
winning their vote so all I'm saying to
you is when we're talking about
you know this is going to get worse this
thing's going to get worse I think you
have to present your argument better to
convert and if we do I think common
sense is going to eventually Prevail
yeah and I I'm obviously not a Muslim
but um I will say this I would much
rather work with a Muslim parent
Association than an lgbtq organization
on the right and they're the opposite is
actually happening people on the right
are trying to go out of their way to go
try to make peace with the gay Mafia
and I think the opposite it's like well
no go to people that actually share some
of your values theological differences
aside you saw in Dearborn Michigan the
parents that were rising up against the
grooming sexual perversion of children
were Muslim families and you see this
with Latinos you see this again with
blacks and Muslims so here here's what
you're getting at Patrick which is very
deep and I agree completely which is
that this woke virus as we call it right
these woke idea pathogens they are they
are
only popular in white upper middle class
college educated Coastal communities and
yet they are being almost colonistically
imposed on the rest of the country so
Midwestern Christians don't want the
woke thing but what there is a
thermonuclear political weapon that's
about to be deployed where you can
exploit how white liberal ideas are
being forced to black youth Hispanic
youth and Muslim youth that has not been
exploited and we're seeing it in the
polling we're seeing it where the Yale
Harvard white Upper East Side liberals
in New York who all agree that the trans
thing is the greatest thing ever they
all want this but you know where it's
unpopular people that still have an
attachment to the customs and the
traditions of their home country that
have not yet been infected by the Yale
Zeitgeist of the chemical castration of
children by the way guys let me tell you
I'm telling you right now this is gonna
sound weird if Republicans win the
Muslim vote and the black liberal vote
it's game over for a few decades and
it's not possible it's not impossible to
do so the presentation has to be better
by purely presenting logic go back to
the well Gallup data and then I want to
hear your thoughts go back on the Gallup
data control F for me because you we
didn't show it so I want the audience to
see exactly control afterward born okay
you found it is this it okay is this
yeah that's out so watch this in your
view of being gay or lesbian something
you're born with or due to factors as
upbringing an environment look at this
this is 2019 is as far as it goes what
does it say born with 49 go all the way
to the bottom that says uh in 1977 13
okay how did this happen this is the
constant trying to baptize people to
think this is normal and they're able to
go to the youngest generation there's
two data points with traditional lists
there's one that says 1.7 percent of
them are gay there's another one that
says point eight percent that are gay if
there's one thing we know about
traditionalists they could give a [__]
about our opinion so they're not going
to be like not coming out of closet
because they're worried about what you
and I think about it they're going to do
whatever the hell they want to do and
then with with these two guys two
communities
imagine all of a sudden a liberal has to
defend a muslim with pure values
you see Elon Omar tap dance around this
whenever she gets asked questions about
this trans stuff or Rashida Talib who
are the two most outspoken Muslim
members of Congress interestingly enough
there was a Muslim attorney general
candidate who lost by 240 votes in
Arizona my home state Abe hamide who
should have been attorney general uh and
there is a sizable Muslim population in
Arizona and he was really clear on all
the major issues and so just to kind of
re-emphasize the point here here's
understandably and Pat you'll have to
meet kind of the right halfway there's
an understandable fear that that
American Muslims have animosity towards
American Christians and vice versa okay
there is some truth to that in the very
radical Islamic circles okay however
we're talking about politics which by
definition is the sport of addition and
multiplication not Division and
subtraction so if you want to multiply
your ranks you have a community of
people that you don't agree
theologically that are currently a
devoted Democrat voting group would it
make sense to then just focus on two
issues that pro-life trans pro-life
trans pro-life Trends Muslims are 99 in
agreement why so so say why is there
that well the vision between the two so
one of it is is a is a unders is a
theological and I share some of this
right belief that radical Muslims want
to bring Sharia to the United States
okay and I'm not saying I even believe
that you know the wholehearted deadly
that that is something a lot of
Christians do believe secondly Post 9 11
there was a fair amount of non-profit
chatter and a fair amount of activism
that presented Islam with no Nuance no
Nuance in the sense of that all Muslims
believe the same thing and that's I
don't think a fair representation right
there's radical Muslims there's people
that take it you know I have a very good
friend Zodi jasser in Arizona who is
calling for a Reformation right but
here's the point is that what I would
challenge Republicans or conservatives
with is like okay let's pretend you
think that Muslims want an authoritarian
regime you're already living under one
you're living under a trans
authoritarian regime and here's a group
of people that want to smash that regime
wouldn't it be nice to build a coalition
for once so let me tell you so I'm I'm
about to get a little uncomfortable with
the audience and they may or may not
like it but that's my comfort zone okay
so we're in Bahamas last week we're
having dinner we're laughing our asses
off for about three hours guy sitting
across from me is the same guy that I
went to and to ask for the Quran that I
gifted to Tate at the end if you watch
the interview with Tate at the end again
I didn't get that far yeah but but if
you just go to the last two minutes
that's all you need to do I gave him a
Quran I gave him a Bible from 1870 and I
gave a Mere Christianity by C.S Lewis
I'm like listen here's three books one
of them is an old Bible one of them
serious news hopefully you read C.S
Lewis you know do your thing he loved
them by the way if you see it the guy
doesn't get emotional you could tell he
got emotional this gift was given to him
and obviously we uh we we have time I
love the fact that Tucker did the
interview with them and he went to
Romania and whether we were the guinea
pigs to realize that you can make it
back to America
it is all good you know well glad we did
that but this is not the one don't worry
about it Roberts it's fine it's a newer
one that's the older one but here's
here's here's what happened there
when we talked to this guy has stutt
love him love his wife Naveen good
people
so he starts talking about Muslims
America Israel Republican Christians and
this guy is a hardcore conservative yeah
maybe more a hardcore conservative than
a Muslim and not saying something
because he is a Muslim and a proud one
and he's the kind that converts he's not
a kind that just talks about it so he's
the kind that converts and he converts
Christians and we I think the number was
shown on how many Americans have
converted to Muslim the numbers like 20
000 Christians of which 75 percent are
women that have 25 are men okay a lot of
them are blacks by the way that are
converting and that's been the case
since the 60s that's been the case since
the 60s
and all this yeah we did but but here's
here's where it went
I said and he said well you know the
challenges that Muslims you know they're
being identified stereotypes with uh you
know being a terrorist and violent okay
no problem so let me ask you a question
I said are all stereotypes correct or
incorrect are they partially correct he
says well Pat I said let me just kind of
give you some stuff here so you ready he
says yes
I said the Armenian I said I'm Armenian
I'm half Armenian half a Syrian I said
Do You Realize AIG flew out to my house
to drop my contract because I was
Armenian because the guy talked to my
wife and said Armenians are known for
insurance fraud and we're worried that
Patrick the same thing's gonna happen
unbelievable the same guy that came with
the lawyer to terminate me seven years
later at his retirement on a yacht he
had five speakers to speak in front of
his entire friends and family the last
one that spoke was his best friend the
second to the last one was me wow that
spoke out we are great friends today
Mutual respected like you would have
been I love this guy I can say that
right
I said okay what are um Asians known for
and we're just asking everybody because
there's a Filipino you know driving okay
Jews okay stereotypes you really want to
say this cheap money okay hey blacks you
know back on black crime you know
fatherless homes okay
you know we kept going everything Indian
uh 7-Eleven in general gas stations
literally everybody and it was all
nationalities so it was comfortable to
say because you're making fun of
yourself you're being self-deprecating I
said when's the last time you heard
about a black terrorist
he says what do you mean I said have you
ever heard about the stereotype a black
terrorist no he's like no I said why is
there you know Middle East Muslim
terrorists why is that connotation there
so while you know it's because there's
so much anger of what the West has done
to this that is okay you go look at the
top 10 countries in the world for the
last 50 years this data's out there if
you look at the top 10 countries in the
world who has the most
you know terrorist attacks violent
attacks against each other eight out of
ten is Muslim of course so now they're
going to sit there and say see I knew
you were against me I knew you were
against this no problem hear me out now
let's flip it on them you ready for the
other side the Muslims gonna like this
part I was born in Iran ten years I
lived in Iran
you know what the West did to Middle
Eastern countries before the Ottoman
Empire fell in whatever 1960 1917 1918
when the Ottoman Empire fell and all of
these countries were part of theirs and
then all of a sudden hey you know we're
going to regulate these guys Palestine
and this and we're going to France and
Britain they're going to have these
countries that are going to you know
regulate hey Iran you guys don't know
how to manage oil we'll take care of
your oil look these people are dumb
let's just take care of their money
their their oil right the British Oil
Company yeah so guess what these guys
are saying no no no no no listen stop
trying to take our money you grown in
our country by creating so many proxy
wars and Havoc Muslims have a good point
there and then there's a statista that
came out showing the the angriest people
in the world
do you know the angriest people in the
world you can pull up the statistic Rob
while we're talking do you know the
angriest people in the world eight out
of ten are Muslim countries yeah why
though because you're raised I'm in Iran
trust me my friends and family if you
come to one of our parties we look like
we're angry half the time for no reason
but I'll say 10 more seconds and I'll
give it over to you and I want to hear
your thoughts on this the point I'm
trying to make right there look at this
angriest countries and go to the top so
people can see world's angriest
countries I think there's a simple
explanation for that by the way if you
look at this one the third one makes a
lot of sense Armenia the third one makes
a lot I mean Armenians Azerbaijan turkey
the whole you know look who's above
Armenia by the way who's angry at who
but this this is the point I'm making to
you
I think if the way it's presented in the
following way listen Muslims Islam
stop like acting like you guys are
Saints and innocent and your history is
beautiful and perfect relax bro you know
you got some dirt in your history fair
but but no no you're right Christians
West relax like hey we got 800 military
bases in the world we're in everyone's
freaking business of course you're gonna
piss people off you want to know about
everyone's business everyone's divorced
leave my marriage alone of course you're
going to create enemies okay now we have
a mutual understanding and agreement
what do we agree on family values and
principles why don't we unite here and
all the other stuff guess what Muslims
do you know in every region in the world
what religion has the most babies per
women
in every region in the world except for
one South and Central America every
other re number one is Muslims guess
what Christians you ain't having enough
babies that's your problem go compete
have more babies these guys are doing
2.9 4.9 you're doing 1.9 2.1 of course
you're going to get your ass handed to
you stop being so upset and go in the
bedroom and make some damn babies you're
making enough of them these are logical
conversations where you can't be like
well I don't want to compete against
Muslims no they're kicking your ass this
is a real conversation of what are you
doing about it so again that's my point
on what I think we can do to kind of get
the two to see a little bit more on what
we're seeing and what weaknesses some
Christians have on this as well your
thoughts yeah I don't want to go too
deep theologically I think there's a
super simple reason why most Muslim
countries have difficult or whether so
angry is because they don't Embrace a
simple Market principle charging
interest is that if you do not have
interest you cannot freely lend out
money now there's some workarounds
around that but you're going to remain
permanently poor if you do not have a
banking system that allows for
entrepreneurial activity I would imagine
that all of us have taken out loans
before usually that's what you're yes
which was used to be outlawed in the
Christian Community
yes how Jews made all the money yes and
uh Jews find a workaround in the book of
Exodus it explicitly actually prohibits
it uh but the rabbis found a workaround
because they realized that flourishing
and prosperity actually comes with the
ability to charge interest right I'm
very pro-interest because then you're
allowed to bet on entrepreneurs and bet
on people to buy homes so I I think that
that's part of it but not not the whole
story I I don't know how deep you want
to get into this theologically Patrick
there are some fundamental differences
between world view of Muslims and
Christians that I think need to be
ironed out but I will get back to I I'm
not that interested in that conversation
I'm just not what I'm more interested in
is understanding that that right now we
are not living in a secular America
we're living in a place where the god of
America has replaced it with trans
zealotry worship of the self widespread
narcissism and kind of a globalist ideal
yeah and so the question is how do you
then defeat that thing and sometimes you
have to make a prudent step that you
might not be thrilled with to partner
with a group of people that you do not
see eye to eye on theologically or
otherwise to build a coalition to win
whether it be in World War II or other
times we as the United States have been
willing to sometimes build coalitions
yeah with governments people and so
again I'm if if a Muslim Imam was here
we'd have a lot of disagreements right
four major differences between Islam and
Christianity off the top of my head you
know I believe in the inerrancy of the
the Bible they believe in the Quran they
believe in the prophet Muhammad one of
the reasons they tend to be a violent
people too is because their Prophet was
a very violent person Christ was not
right
um not not to mention the Trinity they
believe in Allah there's a lot of
differences right however the things we
can agree on in American public policy
is this is as simple as this let's just
start here it is impossible to be a
devout Muslim and vote Democrat it's
impossible how you as a Muslim could
then say you believe in what the Quran
teaches and what Allah commands of you
right and also say it's okay teach this
grooming perversion
Elon Omar Rashida Talib are sitting on
some very very fragile footing right
there and they're only they're able to
capture those Democrat votes over
fear-mongering of deportation or
immigration or whatever their thing is
that's one element of it more
importantly though the most socially
conservative people in America are
Muslims and I I agree with you Pat it
potentially could be some political
upside for Republicans but it's not
going to be easy what you just
summarized both sides giving a little
bit I know the conservative base well
there is there is a lot of skepticism
towards it makes no sense I'm not saying
it makes rational I'm saying it I'm just
I'm telling you the truth of what the
base is saying okay when it comes to
this let me push the bass back let me
push the bass back let me push it back
and push back with me as well because
I'm trying to reason here because
slowly to me on the Republican party I'm
like these guys are only wanting to talk
to people that agree with them and it's
like listen stop being such a pansy and
start kind of like figuring out other
people and how we can create areas that
we can read let me make my point and
then so for example for me here all
right so what's more important to you
being right theologically or
you having the other side gaining the
freedom to teach your kids about trans
and all this other stuff what's more
important to me we can have a
conversation for debate and it's purely
theological totally fine we can have
that debate and Christians are going to
say well you know what yeah I agree with
this guy oh no no I agree with that guy
Muslim is going to say you have no clue
what you're talking fine there's a time
and place for that we're not talking
about that we're talking about an area
where the opposing party
is doing evil things and it's making
evil Behavior seem normal
and I'm not for it
and if I can in a way if if gangs used
to do this in LA
and you have you know a TBR or ms-30
marasaba true or you have blood [__] you
have tuna you know you have black
diamonds all these things that you can
go with with different ganks that they
had in La okay even Armenian power like
listen bro we're Armenian Filipinos had
a strong gank all these guys but when it
comes into this area we have to protect
you in this I'm doing an event in
Glendale no Hotel wants to give us their
location Alex theater who's owned by the
city has 1700 people I went to Glendale
High School they said we know pbd we
follow his content the city is not
allowing Patrick to do his event for
parents at Alex theater I can't do an
event at Alex Theater now we're talking
a couple different hotels every Armenian
Hall in Glendale and surrounding areas
has said you have our place for free
come and do your event there for parents
every one of them we just had a zoom
okay we're trying to find a location
here but for me
to sit there and say yeah you know and
by the way while I'm saying this to you
you know who's the first person I
reached Alex said you know who reached
that former gangsters from MS-13 that
are not Christians devouts saying hey
we'll come and protect making sure
antifa's not going to do anything no
one's going to mess with us trust me
we're going to show up fine
I think we have to kind of figure right
a way to look at uh again we haven't
seen in a long time Charlie uh for a uh
uh Society like ours you know it starts
off with the founder who are the
founders Benjamin Rush you know
Washington all these guys who they
really did the hard job we're doing the
easy job we ain't doing [__] they had it
hard right these 56 guys and then the
founders after those guys shows up
barbarians I'm gonna go build the
railroad what are you gonna do round two
that's what are you talking about let me
do what I'm gonna do with Carnegie Chase
Boomer damn these guys actually pull it
off yes Flagler that's some crazy [__]
industrial okay so those are the
barbarians and they're willing to fight
the fight and any God
you know the builders and the Explorer
what if we can do this and let's go
explore this and let's go exploring and
then comes the administrator well we
need some laws and we need to create
some rules and regulations fine we need
Law and Order then shows up to
bureaucrats and Aristocrats which is the
[__] we're in right now you know who's a
guy that can save that society and the
civilization the synergist who's the
synergist today in America I actually
want to know who is a synergist
everybody is in their own safe tribe
sitting around talking to people that
agree with them who is saying guys can
we do this you got some [__] I got some
[__] you got some [__] let's just
freaking talk because we keep acting
like everybody's perfect we can't unify
the group what if we pull that off so I
think if we were to behind closers I
totally understand what you're saying
because I think you're you're following
is more Christian devout Jesus God
loving all of that stuff and maybe it's
a tough message for you to give maybe
it's a message that a person that's a
like an RFK type of a Muslim that can
give at a turning point USA next year
the following year to kind of give maybe
it doesn't come from you and let the
audience say you have no clue what
you're talking about I two things I
think that there needs to be a
Reformation in Islam I I will stand by
that but my politics right now are about
people say Charlotte motivates you I
want to win I want to win I want to
defeat this woke authoritarian machine
that is taking over everything
everything you do that by addition and
so if there is a group of people that
are growing having lots of kids and
they're being affected by it then yes
but I mean Patrick you know this in
Christianity there is a belief that is
not going to go away that you know the
the the people of Ishmael right in
Genesis 16 I believe it's just it it's
predicted to be that of Toil and
disagreement and Division and some
people have even stronger views on Islam
than on that that is an important
theological discussion happy to have
that with other people but we're talking
about politics
and you can't ever do that if you're not
in power
and you're going to remain in the
minority if you do not capitalize so I
I'm in full harmony with you Patrick so
both can be simultaneously true I
wouldn't I wouldn't demand a Muslim to
like adopt every one of my views if you
know I don't have to that's not the
point right they don't but you don't
have to and they don't have to neither
one of us have to no but I just also
want to be I hope I'm introducing just a
little bit of difficulty of this is
going to be challenging oh brother I I
don't specialize in the uh easy I
specialize
by the way just so everybody knows you
cannot you can talk to Kayla and what I
said to him behind closed doors okay
I get a call from another organization
where you do podcasts for them and I
said you know what I would love for
Charlie to be here with my team I'd love
to have you here to create I'd love to
sign you I'm a big fan of you and I know
you make a lot of money where you know
you don't need to go to anybody you're
doing very well for yourself you're
crushing it I think uh uh if this
[__] 30 under 30 stuff didn't have
anything to do with politics you would
need to be in the top 10 list if not top
five I think that's how powerful and
influential you are I think that's how
important you are I think you're an
incredible Communicator I think you can
reason I think you're smart I think
you're eloquent I think you're tough I
think even when [__] are being jerks
to you you're still gentle with them
respectful with them you let them keep
the dignity that is not an easy thing to
do as a guy how old are you right now
about it you know how hard it is to to
do that at 29 you may not know because
to you it's like normal I've been 29
before and I've been around a lot of
killer 20 year olds who are competitive
it's not easy to do to do so I think you
are a very very important figure in
politics and you will be forever even
last time I talked to you about you know
one day running president all this stuff
you're like Snap what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna be doing King making all this
stuff but I was so impressed by you by
the way you defended the scientist last
time it was so impressive for me and I
got to tell you like I'm like you know
what freaking what a mensch disguise
what a freaking good guy that can be a
guy that can actually unify this group
you're not kind of a guy every one of my
leaders has had you at their events I
don't know who's had you they're always
there and now you're going to be at the
MGM Grand 10 10 000 plus people can't
wait to see what you know khabib and all
these other guys but I think the next
phase Charlie
the role we're gonna play we're gonna
play different I'm not born here so I
have no interest in being a governor
we're going to play a different role by
being building one of the biggest media
companies in the world and we'll compete
and you're on your way and and we'll
have the conversations with everybody
those who hate us those who love us
those who are indifferent those who
don't know us we want to talk to
everybody they're making a big
difference but but I think if there is a
guy
that can play a role of a sinner just
with the way he's wired I think you're
one of those guys thank you I just want
you to consider that when you're
thinking about this leaving here today
and we try to do that at turning point
I'm sorry dude you no and I fully agree
I looked at your date of birth you're
gonna be 30 October 14th 1993.
ridiculous the fact that you're that
you're uh by the way guess what's guess
what sign he is I know you're not a
universe you're a Libra Libra's balance
they're able to have those types of he's
the right wiring to be able to be one of
the center just the next 20 years I I am
so looking forward to your Evolution I'm
44 and for the people that knew me at 29
and and they tell stories people don't
believe who I was at 29 and who I was at
22 or even 18. this is why I love the
fact that my sister uh is one of the
vice presidents in the company doing a
great job polar and cmx I bet you money
and you know uh the family everything
that way because you get to ask those
questions but I think you can play very
big role of a synergist and God knows
America needs it right now well in in
the spirit of being a synergist
um you're gonna have a tough job we all
are yeah and I'll tell you why
everything you were just talking about
with Islam and Christianity and having
the uh the conservative are you what is
even a conservative or a liberal these
days you know that's why uh where am I
going with this this comes down to color
and not the color of your skin the color
of the jersey that you wear I said this
all the time I'm not team red I'm not
team Blue I'm on team red white and blue
and just think about how hard it is when
you're on a team to wear another team's
Jersey just think about that for a
second I'm a huge Miami Heat fan there's
no chance I'm wearing a Knicks jersey
this guy's a Lakers fan there's no
chairs since he's wearing a Celtics
Jersey all right if you're a a Cowboys
fan you're not going to switch over to a
Giants Jersey if you're a Yankees fan or
maybe even anything at this point get it
you're not wearing a bosox jersey so
that is what you're asking people to do
in the Islam community in the Christian
Community in the Jewish Community you're
asking me like liberal conservative to
me I don't even know that I know people
who are quote unquote conservative they
are the similarious liberal sloppy
people I know and vice versa you're
asking people to swap jerseys no we're
not no no that's what
yes in order to to switch votes if
someone is wearing a team red jersey
yeah like that's what they wear and you
want them to wear a blue jersey it's a
very challenging job I am so about to
hire five bis business analysts business
and you know intelligence come in here
pull up the top 20 values of a Muslim of
how they raise their family what they
look at and put it together with
percentage of that being Democrat or
being Republican or independent and that
argument can be made for Muslims to
realize aside from your religion okay
aside from your religion you lean more
towards a Conservative Republican than a
liberal Democrat that bi needs to be
explained to the thinkers then it needs
to be presented to the day-to-day person
and to me the reason why I said I don't
think it's switching jerseys I don't
think you're switching jerseys I think
you're wearing the jersey of a value
that you don't stand for today this is
not John F Kennedy Democrat it ain't
even Bill Clinton Democrat today it's
just not that's right the Bill Clinton
Democrat dude I love those guys let's
talk and by the way again
policy Democrats or John F Kennedy
Democrats today this doesn't make any
sense and I think it's going to get
exposed uh very quickly I got two other
things to do topic was and we'll wrap up
and finish it off so Biden life
expectancy and its implications okay
because I'm actually really curious you
know do you think it's he's going to be
the guy that's going to be running or
not let me just read the story and I'll
go to you so President Joe Biden's life
expectancy is a topic of concern as
voters consider his potential second
term at 80 years old Biden's statistical
possibilities of living to finish his
term is uncertain as you'd expect the
rise the risk of dying increases as we
age says Katia uh irvessi of a nerd
wallet according to lervasi an 80 year
old the male Biden has a 33 31 chance of
dying in the next 33 percent chance 31
chance of dying in the next five years
and a 64.27 chance of that within the
next 10 years however Biden's health
challenges and the stress of being
president raises questions about his
ability to compete complete a second
term if Biden were to win a re-election
but not complete his term vice president
Kamala Harris will become the first
female president so it's agent issue
with you right now do you think Dems are
starting to realize it uh age with Joe
Biden yes or yeah I mean yes but I I
have a contrarian view here where I
don't think candidates really matter
nearly as much as they used to as long
as the Democrats are the only ones that
are investing in meaningful election
infrastructure this is something we're
talking a lot about at Turning Point
action at our big action conference by
the way if you're if you're in Florida
come this weekend tpaction.com just had
to plug that uh and by the way Valley
Tim's gonna have a booth there yeah
tpaction.com but what does election
infrastructure it's data voter
registration election Integrity early
voting ballot chasing I say this
kiddingly but not really they could run
Jimmy Carter from hospice and win
because they can microtarget their
voters run a bunch of ads what a point
and John fetterman is is in evidence of
this so I'm not as interested in the
horse race of the who I'm interested in
the how and the how is the boring but
necessary clipboard and Tennis Shoes
type of Grassroots work that quite
honestly we used to make fun of Barack
Obama for we call them a Chicago
Community political organizer but that's
what they've now built and so for just
one example the game is totally changed
because of covet and our reaction to
coveted with mass mail and balloting
Georgia used to had to used to have 240
000 uh for 247 000 mail-in ballots in
2018 you can look up the number I
believe Georgia had about like 2.4
million people vote by mail in the
midterms in 2022 that's a 10-fold
increase
um and so but that the whole game has
changed then so it went from a Democrat
plus eight State a republican plus eight
state to know a Democrat plus one state
um yeah you could look at the actual
final numbers there so I don't know like
the Joe Biden thing he can't make
coherent sentences can't do all that I
don't know I don't know how much it
matters I think right now until we as
Republicans achieve parity with the
Democrats with the boring stuff of
elections candidates are not going to
matter for quite some time got it I
think you had something to say about
yeah the whole question was Biden's life
expectancy right this is actually
something I know a lot about this is
actually my business I deal in life
insurance and life insurance settlements
you take out a policy on him it's
probably probably too old to take out a
policy but he probably has a policy but
yes I'm very familiar with how life
insurance works and how Life policies
work because I buy them off of old
people understand what I just said I buy
life insurance policies off of old
people and I give them money so it is my
job to actually understand their life
expectancy morbidities literally it's
called it's called the mortality tables
and here's how this works so I actually
did the life expectancy of a couple
different scenarios for Biden's health I
ran it at standard health I ran it at
substandard health and I ran it at
uninsurable Health right if Biden is
considered standard Health right
he'd have 128 month life expectancy okay
standard Health that's 10 years
substandard table two table four right
you're talking 93 to 100 months okay if
he's completely uninsurable for his age
500 rating he'd have a 60 month life
expectancy that's five years so I
wouldn't put them that high you brought
up Jimmy Carter yeah okay Jimmy Carter
98 99 years old he's turning uh this
October right around your birthday by
the way yeah Warren Buffett 92. Charlie
Munger 99 George Soros 92. Henry
Kissinger 100 years old a couple famous
actors Harrison Ford 81 same age as
Biden what he was just in Indiana Jones
Al Pacino 83 DeNiro 79 Pesci 80 Clint
Eastwood 93 uh the list goes on and on
but here's the point we're talking about
Biden and his life expectancy at some
point once you reach 80 something years
old and you're in okay health and you
have money and you have the capabilities
to survive Biden's not going anywhere
and just like you made the reference
like you could run Jimmy Carter at 99
years old that's basically what's going
to happen with Biden yeah and if for
whatever reason he dies or doesn't run
Kamala Harris I think is actually more
beatable than Biden but Gavin Newsom is
a far harder candidate than Joe Biden
totally agree fantastic podcast today
Charlie thanks for coming out again gang
can I just plug one thing of course you
guys want to subscribe to our podcast
we'd appreciate it thank you Patrick
about two things not only to podcasts
put the link to his podcast below and
turning some USA no 100 I was going to
say that so if you're local or you're
not far from get on a flight go to a
turning point USA event uh they got an
incredible lineup of speakers speaking
at this event people that Tucker just
interviewed Tate he's going to be there
president's going to be there uh a lot
of uh people are going to be there it's
going to be a great opportunity to meet
these folks there and put the podcast
there aside from that Charlie thanks for
coming maybe next time you know what we
haven't done yet maybe next time we do a
live with a couple hundred people in
attendance we'll do it and don't so
people can ask you questions as well
thank you thank you take care everybody
bye-bye